This episode of Smartless and our live show was made possible by Ashley, the brand that is supporting real change where it is needed most. Did you know that more than 7 million children are affected by the welfare system and over 368,000 are currently in foster care? So when we heard those numbers, we were shocked. That's why we partnered with Ashley and Sirius XM to make a donation to four others, an organization working to end the child welfare crisis in America. And I got to tell you, it feels really good to be working with a brand that is making a positive impact.
本期的 SmartLess 和我们的现场演出由 Ashley 赞助播出，这个品牌正在最需要的地方支持真正的改变。你知道吗？超过 700 万儿童受到福利制度的影响，目前有超过 36.8 万名儿童身处寄养家庭。因此，当我们听到这些数字时，我们都震惊了。这就是为什么我们与 Ashley 和 Sirius XM 合作，向 Four Oaks 捐款，这是一个致力于终结美国儿童福利危机的组织。我必须告诉大家，与一个正在产生积极影响的品牌合作，感觉真的很棒。
Not only are they generous over at Ashley, they also hooked us up with some incredibly comfy furniture, which is nice as well. And they provided a lot of furniture for our onstage live show. That was also very great because we figured sitting on the floor would have looked very awkward and been very uncomfortable. It was actually like podcasting in a living room, but just nicer than mine. I'm not saying that I fell asleep mid-show, but I might have, you know, listen to Sean and, you know, Jason. Being on an Ashley couch, boy, that'll put you out. Anyway, Ashley offers timeless well-crafted furniture with white glove delivery right to your door. Visit your local Ashley store or head to ashley.com to find your style.
Ashley 不仅慷慨大方，他们还为我们提供了一些极其舒适的家具，这也很棒。他们为我们的现场演出提供了大量家具。这也非常棒，因为我们觉得坐在地板上会显得很尴尬，而且会非常不舒服。这实际上就像是在客厅里做播客，只是比我的客厅还要好。我不是说我在节目中途睡着了，但我可能真的睡着了，你知道的，听着肖恩和杰森说话。坐在 Ashley 的沙发上，天哪，真的会让你直接睡过去。无论如何，Ashley 提供经久耐用、工艺精湛的家具，并提供送货上门并摆放好的白手套服务。访问你当地的 Ashley 门店或前往 ashley.com 寻找你的风格。
This episode of Smartless is brought to you in part by Skinny Popcorn. We had snacks at the live show, thanks to Skinny Pop Original, and which, if you haven't had it, it's deliciously popped. It's perfectly salted. And somehow, it's always the first thing gone in the green room. When I say somehow, I mean Sean and Jason, because as soon as we got there, we had this green room that had all this skinny pop, because like I mentioned, Skinny Pop was one of the sponsors. Those guys, you would have thought that they'd never tried it before. or that they hadn't eaten in years because they just started, they literally, it was embarrassing.
本期的 SmartLess 部分内容由 SkinnyPop 爆米花赞助播出。我们在现场演出中有零食吃，这要感谢 SkinnyPop 原味爆米花，如果你没吃过的话，它爆得非常美味。它咸淡适中。不知怎么的，它总是休息室里最先被吃光的东西。当我说的“不知怎么的”时，我的意思是肖恩和杰森，因为我们一到那里，休息室里就放满了 SkinnyPop，就像我提到的那样，SkinnyPop 是赞助商之一。那些家伙，你可能会以为他们以前从来没吃过，或者他们已经好几年没吃东西了，因为他们刚开始，他们 literalmente，太尴尬了。
And them talking to the skinny pop, people and Sean going like, we really love skinny pop. We're like, yeah, they know, man. They know. Anyway, it was awesome to have them as one of our sponsors. And then I gave those guys so much crap about eating all the skinny pop. And then when I was on stage during the show, I ended up opening a bag and eating it myself.
而且他们跟 SkinnyPop 的工作人员聊天，肖恩说：“我们真的很喜欢 SkinnyPop。”我们就像是：“是啊，他们知道的，老兄。他们知道。”不管怎样，能让他们成为我们的赞助商真是太棒了。然后我狠狠地数落了那两个家伙把 SkinnyPop 都吃光的事。接着，当我在台上演出时，我竟然自己打开了一包并吃了起来。
So, you know, it's a lot of glass houses on this show. It's a recurring theme. And it's one of those snacks where you eat it, and you're like, yeah, I get why it's popular. It's just really good. So Skittipop, it's deliciously pop, perfectly salted, popular for a reason. Learn more at Hersheyland.com slash skinny pop. This special episode of SmartLis was recorded live at the Avalon Theater,
所以，你知道的，这个节目里到处都是“玻璃房”（意指五十步笑百步）。这是一个反复出现的主题。而且这是那种你吃了一口就会觉得“好吧，我明白为什么它这么受欢迎了”的零食。它真的很好吃。所以 SkinnyPop，美味爆开，完美盐渍，受欢迎是有原因的。在 Hersheyland.com/skinnypop 了解更多信息。这期特殊的 SmartLess 是在阿瓦隆剧院现场录制的，
thanks to our friends at Starbucks. And really, what's better than a cold beverage during a live show? We're talking about the ultimate summer sips from Starbucks, whether it's the unofficial drink of the summer, the summer berry refresher, or the new Strato-Frappuccino blended beverage. These beverages are handcrafted to help savor the season. When I was doing the show, I had an iced chai latte. The iced chai lattes at Starbucks are the best.
感谢我们的朋友星巴克。说真的，还有什么比在现场演出时喝上一杯冰饮更好的呢？我们说的是星巴克的终极夏日特饮，无论是夏日的非官方饮品夏日浆果星冰乐（Summer Berry Refresher），还是全新的草莓星冰乐调制饮品。这些饮品都是手工调制，旨在帮助你品味这个季节。当我做节目的时候，我喝了一杯冰美式拿铁。星巴克的冰美式拿铁是最好的。
I love them. I drink them like in one gulp. They're so delicious. Your summer favorites are ready at Starbucks. Good evening. Welcome to Smartless Live. Are you ready to get going? Oh, God.
我太喜欢了。我一口气就能喝完。它们太美味了。你在星巴克的夏日最爱已经准备好了。晚上好。欢迎来到 SmartLess 现场。你们准备好了吗？哦，天哪。
I don't know. I don't know if I want to. How is this guy still? No, you have to do it. Please welcome the guys from Smartless. This Angeles. I think we should start with a little crowd work. Sure, sure.
我不知道。我不知道我是否想去。这家伙怎么还在？不，你必须这么做。请欢迎 SmartLess 的伙计们。洛杉矶。我想我们应该从一点暖场互动开始。当然，当然。
We've never done a little crowd work. Do the wave? Yeah. Fell right off the stage. Last time I was here, I was right about where you were, sir, with belly full of booze watching Smashem Cumpkins play up here. Oh, yeah. That was about 25 years ago when it was the palace.
我们从来没有做过暖场互动。玩人浪？对。直接从舞台上摔下去。我上次来这里的时候，大概就在你那个位置，先生，挺着满肚子的酒看 Smashem Cumpkins 在这里演出。哦，对。那是大约 25 年前，当时这里还叫 Palace。
Anybody? Anybody? And it was just... Just booze, right? Just the booze. Yeah. The last time I was here was for some gay bullshit. No.
有人吗？有人吗？而且只有……只有酒，对吧？只有酒。是的。我上次来这里是为了看一些同性恋的狗屁倒灶的事。不。
Well, happy bride. And also happy bride. Yeah, let's sit. So... Look at this nice Ashley furniture here. Yeah, it's beautiful. Wow, it makes me want to go right to sleep. How many microphones do we get?
好吧，新娘快乐。新娘也快乐。是的，我们坐下吧。所以……看看这漂亮的 Ashley 家具。对，太美了。哇，这让我立刻就想睡觉。我们有几个麦克风？
I don't know. I don't know. Guys, I'm so thirsty. I need a little pick-me-up. Yeah. Under room. Me too. Oh.
我不知道。我不知道。伙计们，我太渴了。我需要提提神。对。在后台。我也是。哦。
It's empty. There we go. What if they were all empty? I was just like, yeah, yeah. And I guess if you're hungry, just... Sure. Sean, what's the prop?
是空的。这就对了。如果它们都是空的呢？我就会像是在说，好啊，好啊。我想如果你饿了，就……当然。肖恩，这是什么道具？
This is, this was so, the people that really make us look good are... That's not your personal? It's what? No, it's not my personal. You don't need to eat while we're doing this. So Rob, Bennett, and Michael, the people that make this show,
这个，这个太……真正让我们看起来很好的人是……那不是你个人的吧？是什么？不，不是我个人的。我们录节目的时候你不需要吃东西。所以罗布、本尼特和迈克尔，制作这个节目的人，
they made this for me because Chin Chin, went out of business. And, you know, I love chin chin, as much sodium as I can get. And so they just gave it to me backstage, and I walked out with it, and I opened it. This is true, they just gave it to me as a gift. And guess what's inside? Oh, I want one of those. Cookies.
他们为我做了这个，因为 Chin Chin（中餐厅）倒闭了。而且，你知道的，我喜欢 Chin Chin，能摄入多少钠我就要摄入多少。所以他们刚在后台把它给了我，我就拿着它走出来，然后把它打开了。这是真的，他们把它当作礼物送给了我。你们猜里面是什么？哦，我也想要一个那个。饼干。
Wait, I won't want that. Yeah. Isn't it when you pick a fortune cookie, you've got to pick the cookie that's smiling at you, right? You know, one of the things, I love that you guys, so who, who, You guys know about Chin Chin and Sean's right affinity for Chin Chin. You guys know about that? You guys are, you guys listen to the show from time to time? You're familiar with some of the characters in the show?
等等，我才不想要那个。对。当你抽中幸运饼干时，你不是得挑那个对你微笑的饼干吗，对吧？你知道的，我喜欢你们这样，所以谁，谁……你们知道 Chin Chin，还有肖恩对 Chin Chin 的狂热喜爱。你们知道这个吗？你们，你们平时听这个节目吗？你们熟悉节目里的某些角色吗？
You guys, you guys familiar with him? We talk about our friend Dan D's. You hear about Dan? Oh, boy. Dan, stick your hand up. Come on, Dan. There he is. I didn't know you're here, Danny. We got Dawn right next to him.
你们，你们熟悉他吗？我们谈论过我们的朋友丹·D。你们听说过丹吗？哦，天哪。丹，把手举起来。来吧，丹。他就在那儿。我不知道你也在，丹尼。他旁边就是道恩。
John. I'm John. Josh is here somewhere. Josh, where are you at? He's maybe on the side. Yeah, there he is. And where's my dad? Josh. Where's my dad?
约翰。我是约翰。乔希大概在某个地方。乔希，你在哪儿？他可能在侧面。对，他就在那儿。那我爸爸呢？乔希。我爸爸呢？
It's my dad here? Oh, yeah. It's just, that's a block away on the 101. No, he's sharing his location. He's sharing his location with me right now. So this says seize the opportunities that will define your future's course. Oh. What does that mean?
我爸爸在这儿吗？哦，对。就在 101 公路旁的一个街区。不，他正在共享位置。他现在正把他的位置共享给我呢。所以这里写着：“抓住那些将定义你未来航向的机遇。”哦。这是什么意思？
Anyway, I have an opening story. I think it means do something. Do you have an opening story? I do. It's really good. You've worked on some bits? I did. I worked.
不管怎样，我有一个开场故事。我觉得意思是做点什么。你有什么开场故事吗？我有。真的很好。你准备了一些包袱？我有。我准备了。
Well, that was the first. But that just was, right? All right, so listen. All right, so this is, I don't know if you guys are going to give a shit. But a couple days ago. By the way, thank you for coming, you guys. We're always amazed that you guys listen to us talk about nothing. But I guess the part that makes it understandable is that you're doing something that is sort of brainless.
好吧，那是个开始。但那只是，对吧？好了，听着。好吧，这个，我不知道你们在不在乎。但几天前。顺便说一句，谢谢你们的到来。我们总是对你们愿意听我们聊这些无聊的事情感到惊讶。不过我想能让这事说得通的一部分原因是，你们正在做一些基本上不用动脑子的事情。
And it's like, well, why not augment it with something that's brain? you're jogging or whatever the hell is. You're riding a, you know, a subway or whatever. But here, you've left your house. I just spit Fortune Cookie on the mic. You've left a house and you're out. Which is new for you. Which is a big deal.
就像是，好吧，为什么不一边做点不用动脑的事一边听呢？比如你在慢跑或者别的什么鬼。你在坐地铁，诸如此类的。但在这里，你离开了家。我刚才把幸运饼干渣喷到麦克风上了。你离开了家，出门了。这对于你来说可是新体验。这可是件大事。
And we're sitting on stage and just talking. And so thank you for doing that. Because there's no music, you know. Yeah, there's nothing. Thank you. Yeah, appreciate it. There's music and... Well, there is a piano.
而我们坐在舞台上只是在聊天。所以谢谢你们这么做。因为这里没有音乐，你知道的。对，什么都没有。谢谢。是的，我很感激。这里有音乐，而且……好吧，这里有一台钢琴。
So you guys are in luck, I think. On the stage. That might be for the... Is that for the mystery guess? It might be for me. It might be for you. Sean does play. We might get, are we going to get a visit from Oscar Levin?
所以你们有福了，我想。在舞台上。那可能是给……那是给神秘嘉宾准备的吗？可能是给我的。可能是给你的。肖恩确实会弹。我们可能会，我们会得到奥斯卡·列文的拜访吗？
Can he visit with us? By the way, you guys should be so lucky. Truly, we've talked about it before. He's a classically trained pianist and, like, to see this guy plays. You better get on there just a little bit today. If you want to be put to sleep, I'll run over there and play. All right, so because it's like... Get to your story.
他能来看看我们吗？顺便说一句，你们可真走运。真的，我们以前讨论过。他是科班出身的钢琴家，而且，看这家伙弹琴。你今天最好稍微弹一点。如果你想被催眠，我会跑过去弹一下。好吧，因为就像是……讲你的故事吧。
Yeah, I can't. People aren't like, I can't wait for classical music. So Scottie and I are unloading the dishwasher this a couple days ago. And we're putting the things away, and we put the tongs in the drawer, the opposite way. Have anybody ever done that? Sounds incredible. Right. Keep going.
对，我不能。大家不是那种“我等不及要听古典音乐”的人。所以几天前斯科蒂和我正在卸洗碗机。我们在把东西收起来，我们把夹子（tongs）放反方向了。有人干过这事吗？听起来太不可思议了。对。继续。
God. You can't top the start. Do you know how much traffic they had to drive through to get here? I get Hollywood on a Thursday night. Okay. You need cards? Sorry, so the tongs. So you're putting the tongs in the dishwasher.
天哪。你无法超越这个开头。你知道他们为了来到这里开了多少拥堵的车吗？周四晚上的好莱坞啊。好吧。你需要卡片吗？抱歉，说回夹子。所以你们把夹子放进洗碗机。
Yeah. We put the tongs in the dishwasher. This is incredible. And we couldn't open the door. What? No way. Hang on, I need another sip from my starboard. Then what, Sean?
对。我们把夹子放进洗碗机。这太不可思议了。然后我们打不开门了。什么？不会吧。等等，我需要从我的星巴克里再喝一口。然后呢，肖恩？
So we couldn't open the door. Uh-huh. We couldn't open the door. Wait, he's checking his cards to keep himself on the store. No, no. Is this a long lie? No, no, no. I'm thinking.
所以我们打不开门。嗯哼。我们打不开门。等等，他在检查他的卡片来让自己不脱离主线。不，不。这是一个长篇大谎吗？不，不，不。我在想。
I'm thinking. So we put it to the thing. And then we couldn't open it. We're like jingling. So then I said, Scotty, get the hot poker from the fireplace, right? Because it's really long. And the drawer had only opened that wide. So we couldn't put our hand there.
我在想。所以我们把它放进那个东西里。然后我们打不开它。我们一直在那儿晃荡。所以我说，斯科蒂，把壁炉里的火钳拿来，对吧？因为那个特别长。而且抽屉只能拉开那么宽。所以我们的手伸不进去。
So we got the hot poker in there. And for two hours, he's trying to get the tongs out. Look, and this is when I have a picture of Scotty after the tongs. Wait, you have pictures to aid the shit story? That's Scotty. And he couldn't get the thing. So then I was like, I was like, wait, I'll, I'll get a wire hanger.
于是我们把火钳伸进去，两小时里，他一直在试图把夹子弄出来。看，这是我有一次拍到斯科蒂在弄完夹子后的照片。等等，你还有照片来辅助这个烂故事？那是斯科蒂。他弄不出那个东西。然后我就想，我就想，等等，我，我会找一个铁丝衣架。
So then I got a wire hanger. We took out the second door drawer, and I put the wire hanger underneath, and I'm inside the thing, and I couldn't get it out for like two hours. I'm almost done, I'm almost done. And then, and so, like, free hope this pays off. You need staff.
于是我拿了一个铁丝衣架。我们把第二个抽屉拿出来，我把铁丝衣架从下面伸进去，我在那个东西里面捣鼓，弄了大概两个小时才弄出来。我快讲完了，我快讲完了。然后，然后，就像是——希望这一切付出是值得的。你需要工作人员。
So then we had to hire a handyman because we just couldn't do it. And so, no, no, no, wait, I'm almost done. And then he comes over and he goes, oh, this happens all the time, which may be fairly good. And then he says, by any chance, you have a wire hanger,
所以我们不得不雇一个杂工，因为我们实在搞不定。然后，不，不，不，等等，我快讲完了。接着他走过来，他说：“哦，这种事经常发生。”这倒挺让人欣慰的。然后他说：“随便问问，你们有铁丝衣架吗？”
and it's like, yeah, but good luck, it doesn't work. 10 seconds, you just got it out. That's the end of the story. Wow. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Honestly. Don't applaud that.
然后我说：“有，不过祝你好运，这招不管用。”10秒钟，他就给弄出来了。故事讲完了。哇。对不起。对不起。说真的。别为这个鼓掌。
Our deepest apologies. You'll get more. Our deepest. And you give me shit for long-winded questions. You have a long-winded story that at least mine ends with a question mark. But I brought a picture. But that picture wasn't, I mean, I wanted to see a picture of you jackasses with the poker. That would have been good to see that.
我们深表歉意。你们还会听到更多。我们最深切的……你们还笑话我问题冗长。你才有个冗长乏味的故事，至少我的故事结尾带个问号。但我带了照片。但那张照片不是……我的意思是，我想看你们两个混蛋拿着火钳的照片。看那个应该挺有意思的。
Yeah, that, like a video. Yeah, or video or something, and it was just the picture of Scotty with dirty hands? Yeah, because of the poker from the fireplace. Did you run this by anybody before? No, I did. You should. You should have. Look at Scotty up there giggling, like the story worked.
对，就像个视频。对，或者视频什么的，结果只是一张斯科蒂满手是灰的照片？对，因为拿了壁炉的火钳。你在之前把这个给谁看过了吗？没有，我看了。你应该的。你真该让人看看。看斯科蒂在台下傻笑的样子，好像这故事真管用似的。
There's Scotty. Didn't. It didn't, Scotty. Scotty, is that how it happened? Hey, what's next on the cards? I have another story or I could intro the guest. No, I want to hear the other story. You do? Yes.
那是斯科蒂。根本没管用。斯科蒂，事情是这样的吗？嘿，卡片上的下一个是什么？我还有个故事，或者我可以介绍嘉宾。不，我想听另一个故事。真的吗？是的。
It's really, this is much faster. So Scottie and I have, I already told you guys. Why am I all the way over here? Oh, come over here. Bring the fucking thing. This thing's all wired. It's a thing bag on it. So Scottie and I both snore
这个真的快得多。所以斯科蒂和我——我刚刚已经告诉过你们了。为什么我跑到这么远的地方来了？哦，过来这里。把那个该死的东西拿过来。这东西带线呢。上面还挂着个包。所以斯科蒂和我都会打鼾，
and we have like, we sleep in separate rooms because otherwise we wouldn't sleep because like every five seconds. And we had, we went through the whole sleep program and we got CPAPs, you know, the thing, the CPAP machine.
我们有，我们分房睡，因为不然我们根本没法睡觉，因为每隔五秒钟……我们经历了整个睡眠疗程，我们弄了 CPAP（持续气道正压通气机），你知道的，那个呼吸机。
And it goes in your nose. Let's not drift over two big, big stories right there. Separate bedrooms. That's not something we all do. Well, you should. You should. You sleep better. And oxygen tanks. Yes. While they sleep. Well, it's hooked here and it pushes... Well, we get it. We've seen it.
它戴在鼻子上的。咱们别扯开话题去聊那两个大故事了。分房睡。这不是我们所有人都会做的事。好吧，你应该试试。你应该试试。你睡得更好。还有氧气瓶。对。当他们睡觉时。好吧，这玩意儿连在这儿，它会推着……好吧，我们懂了。我们见过。
Okay. And it goes over your head and it's not very attractive. So anyway, so I'm lying there in bed and I turn the machine on and once it's on, it's hard to get it. But you can't really open your mouth to speak because the air is pushing to anything. Anyway, so he's stepping over my bed. Getting a hard on. God, how do you guys keep it alive? I mean, this is technically now not show business. What we're doing is not show business.
行。而且它戴在头顶上，看上去不太美观。不管怎样，我躺在床上，打开机器，一旦机器运转起来，就很难……而且你根本没法张嘴说话，因为气流会把任何东西都推开。不管怎样，他就从我的床跨过去。支起了一个帐篷。天哪，你们是怎么保持婚姻激情的？我的意思是，这从技术上讲已经不是娱乐圈的业务了。我们现在做的可不是娱乐圈的事。
Scott, do you want to come down and cry a little bit? So anyway, so he's standing over me and he's just saying good night. And I said, he's like, all right, you're good? And I'm like, yeah, I'm just nod because I can't talk. And he goes, he goes, okay, good night, I love you. And I go, I love you too. Oh, God. Come on, I told you that.
斯科特，你想下来哭一会儿吗？不管怎样，他就站在我上方，然后说了声晚安。我说，他就像是，好吧，你还好吗？我说，行，我只能点点头，因为我没法说话。然后他说，好吧，晚安，我爱你。我说，我也爱你。哦，天哪。拜托，我跟你说过那个了。
And no children, right? What? No what? No children. No children. No children. A dog. A dog named Ricky.
而且没有孩子，对吧？什么？没有什麽？没有孩子。没有孩子。一只狗。一只叫里奇的狗。
All right, let's get to our guest. Ready? Do you want to add something? Do you want to add something? No, I just love just your day-to-day. It's interesting, isn't it? There's such a whole wide world out there. And anyway.
好了，让我们请出我们的嘉宾。准备好了吗？你想加点什么？你想补充点什么？不，我只是喜欢你们的日常生活。挺有意思的，不是吗？外面有那么广阔的世界。不管怎样。
Anyway, next time you come over, I'll show you. I do want to come over and see that. So my guest today, our guest, today. It's your guest. I won't claim the guest yet. Yeah. Writes the kind of songs. Okay. That make you want to text your wife or husband or ex or mistress or hookup or best friend. Or CPAP partner.
不管怎样，下次你来我家，我给你看。我确实想去看看。所以今天我的嘉宾，我们的嘉宾，今天。这是你的嘉宾。我还不会认领这个嘉宾。是的。写那种歌曲的人。好吧。会让你想要给你的妻子、丈夫、前任、情妇、约会对象、最好朋友发短信。或者 CPAP 伴侣。
There are also songs that you'll love and never forget for the rest of your life. He once tried stand-up comedy, collects rare watches like it's a competitive sport. Oh, what... And swears, he's not as intense as he looks mid-gatar solo. He's the reason you bought a guitar or learned how to play the piano. And he's someone I'm proud to call Our Serious X-M Brother. Please welcome one of the most absurdly talented, relentlessly curious, deeply thoughtful, and consistently brilliant artists of all time, John Mayer.
这些也是你会喜爱、并且在余生中永远不会忘记的歌曲。他曾经尝试过单口喜剧，收藏罕见的手表就像在进行一项竞技运动。哦，什么……而且发誓，他在吉他独奏时看起来并没有那么凶狠。他是你买吉他或学弹钢琴的原因。他是让我感到骄傲、并称之为我们的 Sirius XM 好兄弟的人。请欢迎一位才华横溢到荒谬、永葆好奇心、心思极度细腻且始终才华横溢的艺术大师——约翰·梅尔（John Mayer）。
You can see you. How are you? This is fantastic. What do you got on tonight? It's AP. What's AP? Autumn R. P.G.A. Oh, you got a nice glacier blue.
很高兴见到你。你好吗？这太棒了。你今晚戴的是什么表？是爱彼（AP）。什么是 AP？Autumn R.P.G.A. 哦，你戴了一块漂亮的冰川蓝。
Platinum. I'm going to show you for my 50th birthday. So there's an email going. Welcome to the show, first of all. John Mary. John Mary. Thank you. Thank you.
铂金的。我要把它留作我 50 岁生日礼物。所以有一封电子邮件正在发出。首先，欢迎来到节目。约翰·梅尔。约翰·梅尔。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you for having me. Thank you. And it should be noted that we wanted to have you on the show for a long time, which is going to get, going to Jason's story. And I know where you're going to start.
谢谢你们邀请我。而且值得一提的是，我们一直想请你来上节目，这就顺理成章地接到了杰森的故事。我知道你要从哪儿开始。
Well, yeah, you know, the mystery guest thing is a real thing unless it's, you know, like a president or something. We've got to, like, be together and no stuff. No offense. I understand. That sounded shitty. No, no, it's fine.
好吧，是的，你知道的，神秘嘉宾这事本来是真的，除非对方是个总统什么的。我们得一起聚聚并保密。无意冒犯。我理解。刚才听起来有点烂。不，不，这很好。
So there's an email. that goes out the other day about about this. And it says somewhere in the email something about John Mayer. And so I'm like, I'm already here, by the way. She started clapping. But I already him here. It's like with our whole group of us.
所以前几天发出了一封关于这个事情的电子邮件。邮件的某个地方提到了约翰·梅尔。所以我当时就想——顺便说一句，我已经在这儿了。她开始鼓掌了。但我已经在这儿了。这就像是我们整个团队的一件行政事务，关于这就是那回事。然后连同约翰·梅尔，作为嘉宾，照片或者诸如此类的信息。你知道的，我的意思是，我喜欢有点挖苦。所以我回邮件说：“哈，约翰·梅尔听起来是个很棒的嘉宾。希望我们能请他来节目。”他没有回复所有人，对吧？
It's like an admin thing about this is the thing. And then with John Mayer, the guest, the photo or something like that. And you know, I mean, I like a little snark. So I email back and go, huh, John Mayer sounds like a great guest. Hope we can get him on the show. He doesn't reply all, right?
意思是，有人搞砸了，把约翰·梅尔的名字写在了这封邮件里，现在我知道谁是嘉宾了。然后，然后我回答了。继续说，威利，把话说完。好吧，等等。不，说出那个包袱。你们。
Meaning like, somebody screwed up and put John Mayer on this email, now I know who the guest is. So then, and then I answer. Go ahead and finish, Will. Well, hang on. No, do the punchline. You guys. Do it, you guys.
说吧，伙计们。说吧。还发生了什么？好吧，你忘掉的那部分是我说：“对，约翰·梅尔会很棒，”因为我意识到他们已经暗示过那是约翰·梅尔了。对。但杰森并没有真正意识到他们已经暗示过了。你当时不知道。
Do it. What else happened? Well, the part that you're forgetting is that I say, yeah, John Mayer would be great, because I realize that they've tipped that it's John Mayer. Right. But Jason doesn't really realize that they've tipped it. You didn't know that.
你不知道已经定下来了。我以为那是为以后的节目准备的。天哪。这就是我想说的。但这个天才，哦，我希望有一天我们能请到他。这真是个好主意。那可没帮上忙。我妻子在过去的六七天里一直说，你知道，就像是，“我应该穿什么去呢，宝贝？”哦，别担心。穿得时髦点，因为她真的很时髦。然后她说，哦，我说，好吧，你知道，告诉我嘉宾的性别其实并不会泄露太多。所以是个女的，对吧？她说是的，对不起。我说，宝贝，别担心。
You didn't know that it was done. I figured it was for a later episode. God. This is what I'm getting at. But this genius, oh, I hope one day we can get him. That's a great idea. That didn't help. My wife, for the last six or seven days says, you know, it's like, well, what should I
所以连续五六天，她都是“她，她，她，她”。然后，当然了，约翰来了，她就在角落里咯咯地笑。干得漂亮。邮件里明明写了那是约翰·梅尔，老兄。但不是指今晚这一场。我不认为那是针对今晚的。当然写了。上面写了我们今晚要做什么。
wear a baby? Oh, don't worry. Wear something funky, because she's really funky. And she goes, oh, I said, well, you know, telling me the sex of the guest doesn't really give away. So it's a female, huh? She goes, yeah, I'm sorry. I said, baby, don't worry about it.
哦，我这人看书只扫一眼。我只会大致扫一遍。约翰，欢迎来到节目。谢谢你邀请我上节目。很高兴来到这里，约翰。很高兴来到这里。对。你有，你有一对夹子吗？开玩笑的。
So for five, six days, it's she, she, she, she. and then, of course, here comes John, and she's giggling up there in the corner. Great work. It said in the email that it was John Mayer, man. But not for this one. I don't think it was for this one. Of course it did. It said what we're doing tonight.
所以，是的。你还记得咱俩第一次见面是什么时候吗？我们见过。我觉得我们唯一见面的地方是在某人的圣诞派对上。好吧，但我们在那之前就见过，而且我们有一张我和你见面的照片。哦？
Oh, I'm a skimmer. I'm going to skim. John, welcome to the show. Thank you for having me on the show. Great to be here, John. Great to be here. Yeah. Do you have, do you own a pair of tongs? I'm kidding.
嘿，什么，还有照片辅助？好吧，让我琢磨一下这是哪儿。那是《遗愿清单》的首映礼。那是《遗愿清单》的首映礼。是的，你写过，说你想说的话。说你需要说的话。你知道吗，我很高兴你还记得。具有讽刺意味的是，去看那部电影并不是你的遗愿清单。
So, yes. Do you remember the first time you and I met? We have made. I think the only place we meet are at a certain somebody's Christmas parties. Okay, but we met before then and we have a picture of me and you meeting. Uh-oh.
所以，所以，你写了那首《Say What You Want to Say》，那是一首超级大热的歌。我太喜欢那首歌了。但我不知道人们知不知道，这只是个题外话。《遗愿清单》，“遗愿清单”这个词是由电影《遗愿清单》的编剧发明的。真的吗？真的吗？是的。所以人们以为这个词已经存在了几十年，但它真的是为那部电影创作的。而且我相信这是那种事情之一。这有点像《哭泣游戏》（The Crying Game）。人们会引用这个片名。
Hey, what, more picture aids? All right, let me try to figure out where this is. That is the bucket list premiere. That's the bucket list premiere. Yes, what you wrote, say what you want to say. Say what you need to say. And did you know, I'm glad you remember. The irony being that it was not on your bucket list
对。而且我认为这个名字——如果允许我这么说的话，我们俩都曾间接参与过——那是那种电影之一，电影的片名比电影本身活得更久。是的，这不是很疯狂吗？等等，拜托。“遗愿清单”这个词在那部电影之前根本不存在。
to go to that. So, so I, so you, wrote the song Say What You Want to Say, which was a massive hit. I love that song so much. But I don't know that people know, this is just sidebar. The bucket list, the term the bucket list
邮件里写了。这就是为什么这节目能赚大钱。对，不过那是个美妙的夜晚。那是纸业公司的一个美妙夜晚。这不是很神奇吗？我很高兴你还记得。是的，我记得。开玩笑的。所以，等等，从 Sirius XM 好兄弟到 Sirius XM 好兄弟。
was invented by the writer of the movie, the bucket list. Really? Really? Yes. So people believe that that has been around for decades and it really was written for that movie. And I believe it's one of those things. It's a little bit like the crying game. People will reference the title.
是的。你有自己的频道。是多少，14频道？14频道。Life with John Mayer。14频道。我不知道你知不知道。等等，14频道都会播什么？发生什么了？
Right. And I think that the name if I may, we both were involved, tangentially, that's one of those films where the title of the film has gone on to live on a little more than the film itself. Yeah, it's not wild. Wait, come on. The term the bucket list did not exist before that film.
14频道正在发生什么？对，发生了什么？有一天我嗨高了。我突然萌生了一个想法，想要一个广播频道，里面的音乐在一天当中会不断变化，这样无论你一天中的哪个时间打开它，都会有一个专门针对那个小时的播放列表。对。
It was in the email. This is why it gets a big bucks. Yeah, that was a great night, though. That was a great night at the paper. Isn't that amazing? I'm glad you remember it. Yeah, I do. I'm kidding. So, wait, so Sirius Brother to Serious XM Brother.
真他妈的，还真成功了。等等，所以确实有一个比下午 2 点更适合晚上 10 点的播放列表？而且都是你选的？这听起来确实像个嗨高了以后才有的想法。但它真的成功了。我厌倦了用 Spotify。就像，Spotify 对我来说总是像——
Yes. You have your own channel. What is it, 14? Channel 14. Life with John Mayer. Channel 14. I don't know if you know it. Wait, what happens on Channel 14? What happens?
Pandora 也是，对吧。但 Spotify 对我来说总是像你的祖母。就像你祖母在你五岁时了解到关于你的一件事，然后在接下来的十年里一直根据那件事给你送礼物。没错。我记得 Spotify 会对我说：“哦，你喜欢乔治·本森（George Benson），对吧？”
What's going down on Channel 14? Yeah, what happens? I was very high one night. And I had this idea for a radio channel where the music changes throughout the day so that wherever you are in the day, you turn it on, and there's like a playlist for that hour. Yeah.
而我就会说，我告诉过你我只想听一次《Bring on the Night》。对，对。你知道吗？对。或者叫《Give Me the Night》。所以我当时就想，如果我们能打破算法的限制会怎么样？
And some of a bitch, it worked. Wait, so there's a playlist that's more appropriate for 2 p.m. as opposed to 10 p.m. And you pick it all? That does sound like a very high idea. But it worked. I was tired of having Spotify. Like, Spotify was always to me like,
因为最后发生的情况是，你去健身房，你唯一想做的事情就是在锻炼时听点音乐。然后你会说，我不知道，随便给我来首 The War on Drugs（毒品战争乐队）的歌吧。给我放 The War on Drugs。然后你会听到相同的第首歌、相同的第二首歌、相同的第三首歌、相同的第四首歌。
Pandora, yeah. But Spotify to me was always like your grandmother. Like your grandmother would learn one thing about you when you were five and continually give you gifts based on that thing for the next 10 years. That's right. And I remember Spotify, I'd be like, oh, you like George Benson, don't you?
所以我真的觉得它满足了一种需求，而且我喜欢做能满足需求的东西。我喜欢这样。我从中找到了乐趣。就像 SmartLess 移动服务一样。是的。那是什麽，肖恩？哇，肖恩，什么是 SmartLess 移动服务？抱歉，抱歉。
And I was like, I told you I wanted to hear bring on the night one time. Right, right. You know? Right. Or give me the night, it's called. And so I was like, what if there was, we broke out of the algorithm?
什么是 SmartLess 移动服务？我们两天前刚刚推出。这是我们正在做的一项移动通信服务。为什么有人会想要 SmartLess 移动服务？因为你花在手机上的时间里，有 90% 都在使用 Wi-Fi，所以你在无限流量套餐上花冤枉钱了，而你可以节省一半的话费。我现在去 SmartLess Mobile 就能省钱吗？
Because what ends up happening is you go to the gym, and all you want to do is just hear something while you're working out. And you go, I don't know, just give me the war on drugs. Give me war on drugs. And then you get the same first song and the same second song and the same third song and the same fourth song.
绝对可以。告诉我更多。访问 SmartLessMobile。你真的做了这个？我们做了。对，两天前。等你在离开这里之前，我们就要帮你把手机运营商换掉。好了，听着。
And so I really feel like it met a need, and I like making stuff that meets a need. I like that. I get a kick out of it. Like smartless mobile. Yes. What's that, Sean? Wow, Sean, what's smartless mobile? Sorry, sorry.
这真的只需要 90 秒。太棒了。等等，我想知道的是：我能加入吗？可以。所以我们坐在舞台上。这让我觉得不太舒服。我是个害羞的人。
What is smartless mobile? We just launched it two days ago. It's a mobile service that we're doing. Why would somebody want smartless mobile? Because 90% of the time you spend it on your cell phone, you're using Wi-Fi so you're overpaying with an unlimited plan where you can save half of your bill. I can save money right now by going to Smartless Mobile?
我不喜欢聚光灯。我不喜欢拥有……我不喜欢成为焦点。我能看到所有的面孔。这是你非常习惯的事情。对。你从多大开始就在舞台上了？22岁，对吧？对。
Absolutely. Tell me more. Go to SmartlessMobile. Did you really do that? We did. Yeah, two days ago. We're gonna switch your phone before you're out of here. All right, so listen.
你现在 60 岁了？现在 62 岁了。但就像，只是听到你在那个麦克风前的声音，我能看出你有多适应。这真的是……我希望我有这种能力。这就像是……但我希望我能有一个工作，是那种坐在沙发上就会感到紧张的工作。
It seriously takes 90 seconds. Great. Wait, here's what I want to know. Can I get in? Yeah. So we're up here on stage. This is not comfortable for me. I'm a shy person.
你知道的，我看着这一切在想，这是史上最棒的工作。来这儿坐在沙发上。你居然会因为出来坐在沙发上而感到紧张？不，这对我来说不是超级舒服，但你可是个绝对的摇滚巨星。好吧，让我告诉你一件事。那会有所帮助的。
I don't like the spotlight. I don't like having, I don't like being myself. And I see all the faces. This is something you're very comfortable with. Yeah. You've been on stage since how old? 22, right? Yeah.
看着人们，唱歌和弹吉他，那就像是，那是你的……杰森，在场的每一个人，如果你今晚需要一个地方住，都会让你睡在他们的客房里。这是一个很好的观点。这就是你……
And you're now 60? 62 now. But like, just hearing your voice on that microphone and I can tell how comfortable you are. Like, that's, I wish I had that. That's like... But I wish I had a gig where I was getting nervous to sit on a couch.
这就是你在舞台上感到紧张时对自己说的话吗？为什么当在场的每一个人都会让你借宿他们家时，你还要紧张呢？这让我们很好地窥视了一下约翰的大脑。我当时就是这么想的。我当时想：“这里的每个人，
You know, I'm looking at this going, this is the greatest gig ever. To come sit on the couch. Do you're getting nervous to come out and sit on the couch? No, it's just not super comfy for me, but you're freaking rock star. Okay, let me tell you something. That'll help.
如果你需要的话，都会让你睡在他们的沙发床上，那你到底在紧张什么？”去他的沙发床。我敢打赌他们会说：“来参加我们的婚礼吧。”很可能会。你们有没有为了克服紧张而用过《布雷迪部族》（The Brady Bunch）
Looking out at people. and singing and strumming, that's like, that's your... Jason, every one of these people, if you needed a place to stay tonight, would let you sleep in their guest train. That's a great point. Is that what you...
的那招？我们只是想象某人穿着内衣的样子？不，那不管用。管用吗？真的管用吗？你们有谁试过那个吗？有点用。我只是想象自己吃四分之一毫克的赞安诺（Xanax），然后我就能行了。四分之一毫克。然后我就能进入状态。对，我只需要一点点。就一点点。不，你不会那样的。
That's what you tell yourself would you get nervous on stage? Why would you be nervous when every single one of these people would put you up in their house? That's a nice window into John's brain right there. That's what I ended up doing at one point. I went, every one of these people
对，偶尔会。好吧。我是说，好吧。所以这是一个未知的状况。有点不同。我现在没嗑药。但如果我是出来做我的演出，而且有肌肉记忆，那我就不会紧张。但如果是未知的状况，可能会有点……你知道最后经常发生什么吗？
would let you sleep on the futon if you needed to, so why do you nervous about? Fuck the futon. I bet it would be like, come to our marriage. Probably. Have you guys ever to get over nerves done the Brady Bunch
当我是一个惊喜出场时，我开始感到兴奋和紧张，因为我知道我是一个惊喜。你知道我在说什么吗？对。我每天都感到紧张。我每次出来都会紧张。对。因为那是你。你有什么演出前的强迫症似的小习惯吗？
trick? We just imagine somebody in the underwear? No, that doesn't work. Does it? Does it work? Have you guys ever done that? It kind of works. I just imagine myself taking a quarter milligram of Xanax and then I do that. A quarter milligram. And then I manifest. Yeah, I just need a little chip. Just a touch. No, you don't do that.
好吧。我们前几天上了吉米·坎摩尔（Kimmel）的节目。讲讲那个洗碗机的故事吧。他有一个特别棒的故事要讲给你听，约翰。然后甜美、甜美、甜美的肖恩挑了距离吉米最远的一个座位，因为他说：“我不想坐在你旁边，吉米，因为我对这种事情很紧张。我在脱口秀节目上紧张得要命。”
Yeah, every once in a while. All right. I mean, okay. So this is an unknown thing. It's a little different. I'm not high right now. But if I'm coming out to do my show and there's muscle memory, then I don't get nervous. But if it's the unknown, it can be a little... You know what ends up happening a lot of the times?
对，但如果我像今天这样做好准备，我就不会那么紧张。当然。而且如果你不需要的话，你甚至都不会去看那些卡片。不，看着我。好吧。所以你表演过单口喜剧，我超喜欢。我不知道。
When I'm a surprise, I start getting amped up and nervous because I know I'm a surprise. You know what I'm talking about? Yeah. I get nervous every day. I get nervous coming out here. Yeah. Because it's you. Do you have any pre-show OCD-ish things you do?
你表演过单口喜剧。是的。关于你曾经表演过单口喜剧这件事，我之前并不知道。这家伙曾被提名。我单独颁给过他“最佳主持人”。最佳主持人。播客的最佳主持人。
Okay. We did Kimmel the other night. Tell the story about the dishwasher. He's got a great one for you, John. And sweet, sweet, sweet Sean took the seat furthest away from Jimmy because he said, I don't want to sit next to you, Jimmy, because I get nervous to these things. I get nervous on talk shows, big time.
没有。他自己一个人。我这么说是（因为我也演过）。我其实今天在网上读到一个笑话。美国食品药品监督管理局刚刚批准了一种针对女同性恋者的药物。有抑郁症的女同性恋者，它叫 Tri-Cox-Again。
Yeah, but if I prepare like I did today, I get less nervous. Sure. And you may not even go to those cars. if you don't have to. No, watch me. Okay. So you did stand up, which I love. I didn't know.
还行。还不是太差。你有什么喜欢的笑话吗？我是说……最糟的，最糟的……你把包袱剧透了。是的，因为我很紧张。我紧张自己会说错。
You did stand up comedy. Yes. I did not know that about you that you did stand up comedy one point. This guy was nominated. I gave it singularly as best host. Best host. Best host of a podcast.
等等，等等，等等。梅普尔（Maple），我不可思议的女儿，13岁，就在那儿，今天给我讲了个绝妙的笑话。敲敲门，谁呀？谁？哦，对，对。对，等一下，敲敲门。谁呀？
No. By himself. I say that because I did too. I actually have a joke that I read on the internet today. It's the FDA just approved a medication for lesseys. Asbians with depression, it's called tri-cox again.
杰森，你可以跟他们一起。你们开始明白了吗？这就是为什么他能赚大钱。他是个笨蛋，而我比他还糟。跟他们一起，跟他们一起。哦，嘿，敲敲门。布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。敲敲门。
It's not bad. It's not bad. Do you have one that you like? I mean... The worst, the worst... You read the punchline. I did, because I was nervous. I was nervous that I wouldn't get it right.
布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。Oops, I did it again（哎呀，我又来了）。哦，天哪。强尼，我可以演你，杰米。那是梅普尔。你有什么惯用的笑话是你以前常用的吗？我没有演足够长的时间来拥有一个惯用的笑话。你做单口喜剧时的风格是什么？
Wait, wait, wait. Maple, my incredible daughter, 13, right up there, told me a great joke today. Knock, knock, who's there? Who? Oh, right, right. Yeah, wait, knock, knock. Who's there?
我甚至没有……我是说，我，我想成为观察型的。我不是，关键在于，我很高兴我尝试过单口喜剧，因为我现在会和戴夫·查佩尔（Dave Chappelle）一起做演出，虽然我不是冲在最前面的那个，但我能理解他。我看过太多的单口喜剧了，比如，我以前每天晚上都会去纽约市的喜剧酒窖（Comedy Cellar）。我会去喜剧酒窖。我当时完全被它迷住了。当我更年轻的时候，我的脑子里没有那种声音会告诉我，
Jason, you can do it with them. Are you guys starting to get it? This is why he gets a big bucks. He's a moron and I'm worse. Do it with them, do it with them. Oh, hey, knock knock. Brittany Spears. Knock, knock.
那不适合你。所以我看着它，心里就会想：我也要那样。我也要那样。我并没有投入那么多本该付出的时间。我的意思是，如果你真的想做这行，你应该怎么做？拿到你的录像带，看你的录像带。对。而我当时并不想看录像带。
Britney Spears. Oops, I did it again. Oh, God. Johnny, I can play you, Jamie. That's Maple. Do you have like a go-to joke that you used to? I didn't do it long enough to have a go-to joke. What was your style as a stand-up?
我不想。我只是，我只想喝下……刚好足够的酒，去看别人表演单口喜剧，然后心想：我也行。结果并不是那么回事，当你真正站上去的时候，那是一种完全不同的体验，我敢打赌这就像是我其实挺喜欢它的。我其实挺喜欢
I didn't even, I mean, I would, I wanted to be observational. I wasn't, the thing is, and I'm glad I did stand-up because I'll do shows with Dave Chappelle now, and I'm not front and center, but I understand him. I've seen so much stand-up, like, at, I used to go to the comedy cellar every single night in New York City. I'd go to the comedy cellar. And I was just enamored with it. When I was younger, I didn't have this thing in my head that would say,
那种逆流而上的挑战的。问题在于，可怜、甜美、美丽的埃斯特（Esty），也就是纽约喜剧酒窖的节目预定人，第二天会接到《人物》杂志的电话问：“他上台了吗？我听说他说了这个那个。”如果你仔细想想，这就是为什么我不能演单口喜剧。因为如果我
that's not for you. And so I would look at it and I'd go, I'm going to do that too. I'm going to do that too. And I didn't quite put the time in that it would have taken. I mean, what you're supposed to do, if you really want to do it, get your tapes, watch your tapes. Yeah. And I didn't want to watch the tapes.
原因之一。如果我走上台说：“所以我的女朋友又尿路感染了……”那就再也不是一个关于尿路感染的笑话了，每个人都会问：“谁是女朋友？他在和谁约会？”
I didn't. I just, I wanted to drink just. enough to watch someone do stand up and go, I can do it. And it didn't quite and it was a different experience once you get up there, I bet it's just like I liked it. I actually liked
所以这行不通。行不通。甚至连铺垫都行不通，因为人们会纠结于谁是谁、到底发生了什么，但它教会了我舞台经验。它教会了我……而且你大部分的笑话都是关于尿路感染的，全都是尿路感染，基本上。是的。
the uphill battle of it. The problem was poor, sweet, beautiful Esty who books the comedy seller in New York would get calls from People magazine the next night saying, did he go up? I heard he said this and that and that. And if you think about it, here's why I can't do stand-up. Because if I
你从来没费心去开发任何其他的段子。我从来没有真正开发过。我当时做过一件事，就是在最后用一个大木槌把蔓越莓砸碎。对，然后你自学了吉他。这很奇怪，因为它们实际上对治疗尿路感染真的很有用。是的。
one of the many reasons. If I got on stage and I said so my girlfriend has another UTI that ceases to be about a joke about a UTI and everyone would go who's the girlfriend who's he dating?
好吧，我在说出这句话之前就已经考虑过了。这其实是真的，对吧？你笑什么，先生？对。威利，你刚才在喜剧酒窖混了一段时间。威利有一部即将上映的电影，他在里面扮演一个单口喜剧演员，他直接去那儿并跳进了最深的水域。
And so it didn't work. It didn't work. Even the setup didn't work because people would get stuck in who's who and what's going on but it taught me stage time. It taught me And most of your jokes were about UTIs they were all UTIs pretty much. Yes.
布莱德利·库珀（Bradley Cooper）导演的。我们在喜剧酒窖拍的。肖恩也在电影里客串了。如果你眨眼的话就会错过，但确实有。我们的朋友布莱德利导演的，我们在喜剧酒窖拍了八天。我扮演一个因为经历了一些生活变故而刚开始学着成为单口喜剧演员的人。
You never bothered to develop any other material. I never really did. I did this thing where I would just smash cranberries with a big mallet at the end. Yeah, and then you just taught yourself guitar. Which is weird because they're actually really good for curing UTIs. Yes.
你从来没费心去开发过其他段子。我确实没有。我做了这么一件事，就是在最后用一个大木槌砸碎蔓越莓。是的，然后你就自学了吉他。这很奇怪，因为它们对治疗尿路感染其实真的很有用。是的。
Well, I had thought about that before I said it. That's actually true, right? Why are you laughing, sir? Yeah. Willie, you just did some time at the comedy seller. Will's got a film coming out where he's going to play a stand-up, and he went up there and threw himself into the deep end.
嗯，我在说这话之前考虑过。这其实是真的，对吧？先生，你为什么在笑？是的。威利，你最近刚在喜剧卖客（Comedy Cellar）演出过。威利有一部即将上映的电影，他在片中饰演一名单口喜剧演员，他直接去那里迎接了高难度的挑战。
Bradley Cooper directed. We shot at the comedy seller. Sean's in the movie with me as well. If you blink, but yeah. And our friend Bradley directed it, and we shot at the comedy seller for eight days. I play a guy who's just starting to become a stand-up because he's going through some life changes.
布莱德利·库珀导演的。我们在喜剧卖客拍摄的。肖恩也在电影里演了一个角色。如果你眨眼可能会错过，但确实如此。我们的朋友布莱德利执导了这部电影，我们在喜剧卖客拍摄了八天。我饰演一个刚开始尝试说单口喜剧的人，因为他正经历一些生活上的转变。
And so, yeah, so I did the same. It's called, is this thing on and it comes out later this year. Yeah. And it was scary, yes, or not scary? Yeah, the first time I went on, yeah, but I was going on, well, in the same. same way. I was going on as they introduced me as this character as the guy
所以，对，我也是这样。这节目叫《这玩意儿开着吗》，今年晚些时候上线。对。而且当时挺吓人的，对吧，还是不吓人？对，第一次上台的时候，对，但我是以同样的方式上去的。他们介绍我的时候，就把我当成那种……
who's going up doing stand-up at the first time. Then people were very confused. A guy looks a lot like well-armed. And I'm like, hey, I'm going through a divorce. I'm getting divorced. And people are like, didn't he get divorced like 10 years ago? Amy Polar? Like, you know? And it was very confusing for people.
第一次上台说脱口秀的家伙。然后大家都非常困惑。一个长得很像全副武装……而我就像，嘿，我正在经历离婚。我要离婚了。大家就会想，他不是大概10年（前）才离的婚吗？艾米·波勒？就像，你知道的？这对大家来说非常困惑。
But we made the leap anyway, yeah. But did you see anyone you loved when you were there? Did you get a ton. Yeah. So many good. And they're so good and it's so hard what they do. You have so much, you end up having so much respect for stand-ups and what they do. It's amazing. And writing jokes all day.
但我们不管三七二十一还是迈出这一步，对。不过你在那儿的时候看到任何你爱的人了吗？你拿到了超多……对。有那么多好节目。他们太棒了，而且他们做的事情太难了。你会有很多，你最终会对脱口秀演员以及他们的工作产生极大的敬意。这太神奇了。而且整天都在写笑话。
So we would go back and we'd write jokes all day and then go at like 9 o'clock and meet up there and go up three or four times at all the different stages. It was pretty crazy. There's really nothing like it. And everyone has a friend that's told them you should do stand-up or the other way around. And when you get up there,
所以我们会回去，整天都在写笑话，然后在大概9点钟去那儿汇合，在所有不同的舞台上登台三到四次。这真是太疯狂了。真的没有什么能与之相比。每个人都有一个朋友，对他们说你应该去说脱口秀，或者反过来。当你走上台去，
you realize the water is choppy. And what's crazy is, it's true. And what's crazy is, As Jason pointed out, you've been performing in front of huge audiences for a long time. And I've been doing this for a long time. I look really young, but I'm older than... And they're laughing because it's so true. And...
你就会意识到水面波涛汹涌。而疯狂的是，这是真的。而疯狂的是，正如杰森所指出的，你长期以来一直在巨大的观众面前表演。而我做这个已经很久了。我看起来真的很年轻，但我比……他们都在笑，因为这太真实了。而且……
And yet, when you actually go do stand-up, it is just such a different thing. It's completely different. We did one night when we were prepping for the movie. John, we're going to get to you in a sec. This is great. No, this is great. I was laughing just thinking as I was drifting as he was talking. I was thinking to my...
然而，当你真正去说脱口秀时，它完全是另一码事。它完全不同。我们在为电影做准备的那天晚上做过一次。约翰，我们一会儿就聊到你。这太棒了。不，这太棒了。我刚才走神想着他说话的时候，我就在笑。我在心里想……
Because I drifted far. I thought, this is actually the most fun I've had on a podcast so far. I like where we're going. I like where we're going. You're lucky to get a word in. It's a conversation. I like where we're going. My point was, the line between succeeding, killing, and bombing is very thin.
因为我走神走得太远了。我想，这其实是我迄今为止在播客中玩得最开心的一次。我喜欢我们谈论的方向。我喜欢我们谈论的方向。你能插上一句话算你走运。这是一场对话。我喜欢我们谈论的方向。我的意思是，成功、大获成功和砸场子之间的界限非常薄。
So the first guy who brought me on stage... Quickly, please, yeah. We have to get to these guys. I'll have you know was the dearly departed Bob Sagitt. How bad do you feel now? now. And Bob brought me on stage, which meant he went up for just probably
所以第一个把我带上舞台的人……快点，拜访，对。我们得聊聊这几位了。我不妨告诉你，他就是已故的鲍勃·萨吉特。你现在觉得有多糟糕？现在。鲍勃把我带上台，这意味着他大概上台讲了
four or five minutes, which was impossible for Bob to do, to do four or five minutes. Even more impossible now. That is true. That is, that is true. Bob would appreciate it. Well, you ask me how he would appreciate that job. Which is why you can do it. And he brought me up on
四五分钟，这对于鲍勃来说是不可能的任务，讲四五分钟。现在更不可能了。那是真的。那是，那是真的。鲍勃会欣赏这个的。好吧，你问我他会怎么欣赏那个工作。这就是为什么你能做到。他把我带上了
stage, and I immediately felt how difficult it was and this is the real problem. This is the real. I'm trying to put you in my shoes if you were to do stand-up. You might absolutely suck, but all you want to do when you get off stage is do it again.
舞台，我立刻感受到了它的艰难，而这才是真正的问题。这才是真实的情况。我试着让你设身处地想想，如果你去说脱口秀。你可能会糟透了，但你下台后唯一想做的事就是再来一次。
And again, there's something about it. It's a little kind of million-dollar baby where you're all beat up and you're all, see you tomorrow morning. Yeah, it's crazy. It's crazy. Now, Sean tried, and you guys have probably heard a little bit if you listen to the podcast, but Sean tried to stand-up once and he had a great opening. You remember his great opening show?
而且一遍又一遍，这其中有一种奇妙的感觉。有点像《百万美元宝贝》，你被打得遍体鳞伤，然后大家说，明天早上见。对，这太疯狂了。太疯狂了。现在，肖恩尝试过，如果你听过这个播客，你们可能略有耳闻，但肖恩尝试过一次脱口秀，他有一个很棒的开场。你还记得他那个精彩的开场秀吗？
It's the best. Let's hear it, Sean. It's not the quiet, the level of the tongue story, You love it, John. They say doing ballet is one of the most difficult things you could ever do. So I say just don't do it. End of joke. That's it.
太棒了。让我们听听，肖恩。这不是那种安静的、那种老生常谈的故事，你一定会喜欢的，约翰。他们说跳芭蕾是你能做的最困难的事情之一。所以我说那就别跳了。笑话讲完。就这样。
That's the kind of logic I like. I like that kind of tail-eating logic. You can use it. John, you grew up in Fairfield, Connecticut. Yes, I grew up in Fairfield, Connecticut. Yeah. You grew up in Fairfiel. Your mom was an English teaching your dad
我喜欢这种逻辑。我喜欢这种自圆其说的逻辑。你可以用它。约翰，你在康涅狄格州费尔菲尔德长大。是的，我在康涅狄格州费尔菲尔德长大。对。你在费尔菲尔德长大。你妈妈是个英语老师，你爸爸
a high school principal. So, I mean, what? Did you feel like you had to be on your toes all the time with your grades and learning and all that? I had a very nice kind of hybrid of right brain, left brain growing up because there would be like, if you had a question about a word, the dictionary would come out at the dinner table. Oh, really? And you would break down what that word was. But then I would also go in my room and kind of escape from all of it and just play guitar. And if you put both those things together, it's very good for being a singer-songwriter.
是个高中校长。所以，我的意思是，什么？你觉得你从小到大在成绩、学习以及诸如此类的事情上都必须时刻保持警惕吗？我的成长过程中有一种非常好的人脑左右脑结合体，因为会有这样的情况，如果你对一个词有疑问，字典就会在饭桌上拿出来。哦，真的吗？然后你们会剖析那个词是什么意思。但随后我也会回到自己的房间，算是从这一切中逃离出来，只是弹弹吉他。如果你把这两件事结合起来，对做一个唱作人来说是非常好的。
because you've got the left brain, right brain thing going. So I hear things when people are talking to me. I know what's wrong with all of the grammar they're using, and I just let it go now. Does it drive you crazy? Do you still drive me crazy a little bit? There's a couple ones that drive me crazy, and it's number and amount. Do you know about number and amount?
因为你同时拥有左脑和右脑的功能。所以我跟人谈话时能听出弦外之音。我知道他们使用的语法有什么问题，我现在只是不予计较。这会把你逼疯吗？你还是会让我有点抓狂吗？有几个用法确实让我抓狂，那就是“number”（数量，指可数）和“amount”（数量，指不可数）。你知道number和amount的区别吗？
No, tell me. I'm going to change your life forever, and you're going to annoy all your friends. It is a number of people. It is an amount of butter. So number refers to a quantifiable substance. A bunch of singular things. Yes. And amount is the opposite of that.
不，告诉我。我要彻底改变你的人生，而你会惹恼你所有的朋友。It is a number of people（是一群人）。It is an amount of butter（是一定量的黄油）。所以number指的是可量化的物质。一堆单数的事物。是的。而amount则与此相反。
So when you hear amount of people, it is technically wrong. Number of people. And when you hear someone say number of people, to me, it's like music to my ears. What about punctuation with texting, emails, things like that? Periods go inside of the quotes. Right? You know? Exactly.
所以当你听到amount of people（人数，错误用法）时，它在技术上是错的。应该用number of people。而当你听到有人说number of people时，对我来说，这简直就像天籁之音。那发短信、发邮件等情况下的标点符号呢？句号要放在引号里面。对吧？你知道吗？没错。
Commas go inside the quotes. Exactly. I believe question marks go outside the quotes. There's a book called Eats, Shoots and Leaves. You said, no, it they don't? It depends. It depends. If you're relaying what somebody else said, right?
逗号要放在引号里面。没错。我相信问号应该放在引号外面。有一本书叫《食、射与留》（Eats, Shoots and Leaves）。你说，不，它们不是？这得看情况。这得看情况。如果你是在转述别人说过的话，对吧？
Then it would go in, but if you're asking, did she say this, then it would go outside. Right. But then it's not a double dash for the quotes. It's a single dash because it's somebody else's... Right. If I'm writing, I will actually do several layers of quotes, so I'll use the single apostrophe for the quotes inside of the double apostrophe for what it was saying. I think it's beautiful.
那它就应该在里面，但如果你是在问，她说过这个吗，那它就应该在外面。对。但接着，引用的符号就不是双破折号了。而是单破折号，因为那是别人的……对。如果我在写作，我实际上会做好几层引号，所以我会在双引号里面用单引号来引述当时所说的话。我觉得这很美。
It's a beautiful thing. Well, not all heroes wear capes. But are you one of those cool texters that, like, uses acronyms and, like, how, the kids' text? No, you'll write a goddamn sentence, right? And you'll punctuate it. You'll spell check it, and then you'll send it. I have one pet peeve. Yeah.
这是一件很美妙的事。好吧，并非所有的英雄都穿着披风。但你是那种酷炫的、喜欢用缩写的发短信的人吗，比如，孩子们是怎么发短信的？不，你会写一个该死的句子，对吧？而且你会加上标点符号。你会进行拼写检查，然后发送。我有一个讨厌的习惯。对。
Which is when people use hung for when someone was hanged. It's hanged, not hung. That comes in handy a lot. Yeah. Because he searches it on Google all the time. Do you have that, John, where you feel like the urge to correct people? I will tell you, I have a rule. I have a rule.
那就是当人们把本该用“hanged”（绞死）的地方用成了“hung”（悬挂）。应该是hanged，而不是hung。这经常派上用场。对。因为他一直在谷歌上搜索这个。你有这种感觉吗，约翰，那种忍不住想纠正别人的冲动？我告诉你，我有一个原则。我有一个原则。
If I feel like it will help them and they will appreciate that help, I'll do it. And I'll have a way of saying, there's nothing wrong with you saying it to me. I think you'd want to know, and I want you to, so you can judge it. Here's one that's just a real dude. When I'm looking at an Instagram caption, and someone says they were honored to be a part of something, but apart is one word apart, which is the exact opposite of what they're saying. That one is bonkers.
如果我觉得这能帮到他们，而且他们会感谢这种帮助，我就会去做。而且我会有表达的方式，你对我指出这一点也没什么不对。我想你会希望知道，而且我希望你知道，这样你就能做出判断了。这里有一个绝对让人抓狂的例子。当我在看Instagram的图说时，有人说他们很荣幸能成为某事的一部分（be a part of），但apart（分开的）却写成了一个词apart，这跟他们实际要表达的意思完全相反。那个简直太离谱了。
Or what about when you're sending a text? The send button is not a period. You know, create your paragraph. Send that. Don't just keep hitting send at the end of every sentence. Because then my phone goes, I feel like someone died. This has been about a year and a half to two years now.
或者当你发短信时呢？发送键可不是句号。你知道的，写好你的段落。发送那段。不要在每个句子的结尾都一直按发送键。因为那样我的手机就会一直响，我觉得就像有人去世了一样。这种情况大概已经持续了一年半到两年了。
I promise we're going to get back to the show. This became, listen, we're on a hot streak. This became a kind of vernacular where people would say, I mean, not for nothing, but we should. And it's cool if you have that text open. And if you're watching something and it keeps coming down, or if he's trying to show a video of people getting hunged. There aren't alerts.
我向你们保证，我们马上就会回到节目中来。这就变成了一种，听好了，我们正处于连胜状态。这就变成了一种俗语，人们会说，我的意思是，并非无缘无故，但我们应该。如果你打开那个聊天界面，这倒挺酷的。如果你在看某个东西，而它不断弹下来，或者如果他试图展示一个人们被hunged（错误用法，应为hanged）的视频。没有什么提醒。
Then you would just see it coming down and stuff. And so now just write it all. I put paragraph breaks in now. Take your time. Right. Get it together and then alert me to what you want to talk. At the same time, it does make it more conversation. I'm not here defending that and I'm not guilty of it.
然后你就会看到它不断弹下来之类的。所以现在就一次性写好吧。我现在会加上段落分隔。慢慢来。对。组织好语言，然后再提醒我要谈的事情。与此同时，这确实让交流变得更多了。我不是在为这种行为辩护，我也没这么干过。
But I will say there's also nothing worse. You're the absolute worst. There's nothing worse than getting six inches of text from somebody. Glad you finished the sentence. Here's this story. You know what I mean? You would love my texts. I bet.
但我必须说，也没有什么比这更糟糕的了。你绝对是最糟糕的。没有什么比收到某人发来的六英寸长的短信更糟糕的了。很高兴你终于把话说完了。故事是这样的。你知道我的意思吗？你会喜欢我的短信的。我敢打赌。
Can you text? I'm important to texting with you. Try me. Try me. I'm ready to start a friendship with you. I'm saying it officially right now in front of everybody. I'll never be uninteresting. No, I saw you at the Mets game the other day.
你能发短信吗？我和你发短信很重要。试试我。试试我。我已经准备好和你开始一段友谊了。我现在当着所有人的面正式宣布这一点。我绝不会变得无趣。不，我前几天在大都会队的比赛中看到你了。
I'm like, we can go to baseball games. You can teach me how to play guitar. You and I... I know, this is sort of like the We Never Hang Out Dave thing you're doing, but I would hang out with you. I'll get you on Smartless Mobile. That's great.
我想，我们可以去看棒球比赛。你可以教我弹吉他。你和我……我知道，这有点像你那种“我们从不一起出去玩”的戴夫梗，但我会跟你一起出去玩的。我会让你上“Smartless Mobile”移动网络。那太棒了。
We'd love to get you on. Yeah, listen, I would love to have a Samsung phone. That sounds very exciting. He's kidding. You can get it on any phone. I can't wait to have red bubbles. I'm John Why are your bubbles red?
我们很乐意邀请你上节目。对，听着，我很想拥有一部三星手机。听起来非常令人兴奋。他在开玩笑。你可以在任何手机上使用它。我等不及要用红色的气泡框了。我是约翰，为什么你的气泡框是红色的？
I'm on smartless mobile It's not true It's all blue It's 5G and you're on the T-Mobile network Anyway John Smartless mobile alerts Sounds like you don't want a free fucking phone I just love the idea of being on
我在用Smartless Mobile。这不是真的。全都是蓝色的。这是5G，你用的是T-Mobile网络。不管怎样，约翰，Smartless Mobile提醒……听起来你才不想用免费的狗屁手机呢。我只是喜欢那种身处……
Hit me up on Like you guys have to start integrating it into your casual conversation You hit me up on my smartless mobile We didn't have to We didn't know that Sean was going to drop to be honest. It's fun.
在随意的谈话中把这个融入进去，你们这些家伙必须开始这么做了。你在我的Smartless Mobile上联系我。我们本来不用这样的。老实说，我们不知道肖恩会突然来这一出。这很有趣。
And we will be right back. This episode of SmartList is sponsored by our friends at Ashley. The brand actually made our live event stage feel kind of like a home, while also supporting incredible organizations like Four Others. Earlier in the episode, we mentioned
我们马上回来。本期SmartList播客节目由我们的朋友Ashley赞助。这个品牌实际上让我们的现场活动舞台感觉像一个家，同时也支持像“For Others”这样不可思议的组织。在节目早些时候，我们提到了
their donation to Four Others, a nonprofit doing very, very, very important work to end the child welfare crisis in America. The crisis may go overlooked at times, But it has serious consequences. And through working with Ashley and for others, we learned that 90% of children in the welfare system will experience severe trauma.
他们对“For Others”的捐赠，这是一个致力于结束美国儿童福利危机的非营利组织，做着非常、非常、非常重要的工作。这场危机有时可能会被忽视，但它会带来严重的后果。通过与Ashley和“For Others”的合作，我们了解到福利系统中有90%的儿童会经历严重的创伤。
And children that age out of the foster care system have a 40% chance of being homeless within 18 months, with 97% immediately entering chronic poverty. And these stats are hard to hear, but that's exactly why this work is so important. So through Ashley's donation, the next generation can find a loving and secure home, strengthening our communities and opening doors to new possibilities.
而在寄养系统长大成人的儿童在18个月内无家可归的几率高达40%，其中97%的人会立即陷入长期贫困。这些统计数据很难让人接受，但这正是这项工作如此重要的原因。因此，通过Ashley的捐赠，下一代可以找到一个充满爱与安全的家，从而加强我们的社区并为新的可能性打开大门。
And we're just thrilled to celebrate the powerful work being done by four others with Ashley's support. We were sitting on Ashley pieces during the live taping of our show, which was comfy and they looked great. It made it look like a living room and kind of at times forgot we were on stage. But sitting on Ashley's furniture knowing the work that they did, do that goes and does good in the world felt even better. And just being associated with that brand for us went a long way. Ashley's all about style that's made for real life with white glove delivery right to your
我们非常高兴能借助Ashley的支持，来庆祝“For Others”所做出的伟大工作。在我们节目的现场录制期间，我们坐在Ashley的家具上，它们非常舒适，而且看起来也很棒。这让现场看起来像一个起居室，有时候甚至让我们忘记了自己是在舞台上。但坐在Ashley的家具上，一想到他们所做的工作能够为世界带来美好，这种感觉就更好了。对我们来说，能够与这个品牌联系在一起意义重大。Ashley专注于为真实生活打造的时尚，并提供直接送货上门的白手套服务。
door. So visit your local Ashley store or head to ashley.com to find your style. To learn more about For Others mission or to donate, visit For Others.com. This episode of Smartless is brought to you in part by Skinny Popcorn. And yes, it's exactly what you heard, crunching. backstage at our live event at the Avalon. I will say there's something kind of really classic about the original skinny pop. No fluff.
所以请访问你当地的Ashley商店，或者前往ashley.com寻找你的风格。要了解更多关于“For Others”的使命或进行捐赠，请访问ForOthers.com。本期SmartList部分内容由Skinny Pop爆米花为您呈现。是的，正如你所听到的，我们在阿瓦隆剧院（Avalon）的现场活动后台传来了嘎吱嘎吱的咀嚼声。我必须说，原味Skinny Pop有一种非常经典的感觉。没有花哨的添加。
It's just got the good stuff. It's deliciously popped, perfectly salted, light and airy. Kind of like me. I feel like I'm kind of light and airy. I'm like a human skinny pop. But I'm not as good. We did. We had so much skinny pop.
只有好东西。它爆得美味，咸淡适中，轻盈又蓬松。就像我一样。我觉得我有点轻盈又蓬松。我就像一个人类版的Skinny Pop。但我没那么好吃。我们确实吃了。我们吃了好多Skinny Pop。
They were a sponsor of the show. And we had so much of it everywhere. were kind of silly with Skinny Pop, and the guys went a little bit crazy with it. Every time I buy Skinny Pop, in my mind, I'm always like, oh, I'm getting it for the kids because I have two teenagers and a little guy. And I'm like, so I'm getting Skinny Pop for the kids. It's a good snack, and it's a snack that I sort of feel comfortable having in the house. And then, invariably, I'm the one who eats it all.
他们是节目的赞助商。到处都是。我们在Skinny Pop这事上有点犯傻，大家都有点为此疯狂。每次我买Skinny Pop时，我的脑海里总是想，哦，我是为孩子们买的，因为我有两个青少年和一个小家伙。所以我想，我是为孩子们买Skinny Pop。这是一款不错的零食，也是一款让我觉得放在家里很放心的零食。然后，毫无例外，最后把它全吃光的人总是我。
Skinny Pop, deliciously pop, perfectly salted, popular for a reason. Find out more at Hersheyland.com slash Skinny Pop. You're listening to a very special episode of SmartList recorded at the Avalon Theater, and we've partnered with Starbucks to help make this summer even more memorable. This season, Starbucks is delivering handcrafted beverages made to inspire you to enjoy the summer season to the fullest. We're talking bold, refreshers, iced beverages, and a new Frappuccino that all tastes like summer with each sip. I've been sipping between takes, and let's just say, none of us are sharing. Your summer favorites are ready at Starbucks. Stop by your local store and enjoy your favorite tastes of summer.
Skinny Pop，美味爆米花，咸淡适中，大受欢迎是有原因的。在Hersheyland.com/SkinnyPop了解更多信息。你正在收听的是一期在阿瓦隆剧院录制的非常特别的SmartList节目，我们与星巴克合作，让这个夏天更加难忘。这个季节，星巴克为您提供手工饮品，旨在激发您充分享受夏日时光。我们谈论的是浓郁的提神饮品、冰镇饮品，以及一款全新的星冰乐，每一口都充满了夏日的气息。我在录制间隙一直在品尝，咱们这么说吧，我们谁都没有分给别人。您的夏日最爱已在星巴克准备就绪。快去您当地的门店，享受您最喜爱的夏日风味吧。
And now back to the show. So you're from Connecticut, and I remember I was in Atlanta once. J.B. and I spent a couple of years there, not together. And I was listening to a radio station driving to work, and then you were talking to the people, and you knew these people on the radio. And I guess I missed the first. You had a real connection to Atlanta at the start of your career. Is that true?
现在，回到节目中。所以你是从康涅狄格州来的，我记得我曾经在亚特兰大待过。J.B.和我曾在那里度过几年，不是一起去的。当时我开车去上班时听着一个广播电台，你在和听众交谈，你认识电台里的这些人。我想我错过了开头。在你的职业生涯刚起步时，你和亚特兰大有着真正的渊源。这是真的吗？
Yeah, I moved down to Atlanta when I was... Pariat. Go ahead. Like a real connection. Yeah, I went down to Atlanta, moved away. I left Berkeley College. of music after a year, moved down there with a friend
对，我搬到亚特兰大时……请便。继续。就像真正的渊源。对，我去了亚特兰大，后来又搬走了。我读了一年伯克利音乐学院后就离开了，和一个朋友一起搬到了那里。
and just started writing songs and plugging away and going for it. I had a friend who was from there down in Snellville, Georgia, where everyone is someone is what they say down there. Which is really nice now when you look at it that way.
然后就开始写歌，坚持不懈，全力以赴。我在那儿有一个朋友，来自佐治亚州的斯内尔维尔（Snellville），那里的人正如他们自己所说的那样，每个人都是个腕儿。从那个角度来看，现在想来真的很不错。
And so I moved down there and we started writing songs and I just... How old were you? 21? But didn't you start writing in high school? Yeah, I started writing songs. And you were like a gas station person?
所以我搬到了那里，我们开始写歌，而我只是……你当时多大？21岁？但你不是在高中时就开始写作了吗？对，我开始写歌了。你当时像是在加油站工作的人吗？
I worked at a gas station. I was writing songs. I was writing songs in math class. I mean, see, that blows my mind that, I mean, it's so rare to have that gift at such a young age to be able to use the English language, then put it to music, and you just happened to be an incredible songwriter. And you knew this at such a young age. Did you know why you were pumping gas at the gas station?
我在加油站工作。我在写歌。我在数学课上写歌。我的意思是，看，这让我大开眼界，也就是说，在那么年轻的时候就能拥有那种天赋，能够运用英语，然后把它谱成曲，而你恰好是一位不可思议的词曲作者，这真是太罕见了。而且你在这么小的年纪就意识到了这一点。当你在加油站抽油时，你知道原因吗？
Did you have enough belief in yourself to know that, oh, this is just temporary? I'm probably going to make it someday. Everything, yeah. I mean, everything that I was looking at was in my way. And there are kids out there who feel this way, and my heart goes out to them. They're not being punks. They're acting out in class,
你对自己有足够的信心，知道“哦，这只是暂时的，我总有一天会成功的”吗？一切，对。我的意思是，我所看到的一切都挡在我的路上。有些孩子也是这种感觉，我的心与他们同在。他们并不是小混混。他们在课堂上调皮捣蛋，
but they're not being punks. They already know. It would be like going to a restaurant, and the waiter is reading the specials, and you go, I know what I want. I don't want that. I just want the burger. And they're telling you about,
但他们并不是小混混。他们心里早就明白了。这就好像你去一家餐厅，服务员在念今日特色菜，而你说：“我知道我想吃什么。我不要那个。我只要汉堡。”而他们还在向你介绍：
we take the lobster out, we cook it, we put it back in the show. You're like, I know what I want. And it was very, it was, That was actually one of the hardest times in my life, was to have to be 15. When I knew that I wasn't 15, I wanted to go do this thing. Wow.
“我们把龙虾拿出来，煮熟，然后再放回壳里。”而你会说：“我知道我想吃什么。”这真的非常……那其实是我一生中最艰难的时光之一，那就是在15岁的时候。当我明明知道自己不甘于15岁，我想去做那件事的时候。哇。
I love that. I love the way you put that, yeah. So then when did the damn break? When was it like, yes, finally I'm getting some traction. They're playing my music. Well, I went to Berkeley College of Music when I was 19. I took a couple years off to hone my chops at the mobile station. But by the way, let me also say,
我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢你表达的方式，对。那么，水坝是什么时候决堤的？什么时候开始有这种感觉的：“太好了，我终于有点名气了，他们在播放我的音乐。”好吧，我19岁时去了伯克利音乐学院。我休学了几年，在美孚加油站打磨我的本领。顺便说一句，我也想说，
whatever job you have, be the best at it on your way to where you're going. Be the best at. I became assistant manager at the mobile station. I remember seeing the interview. Did you go there with like Diane Sawyer? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like 25 years ago. 30 years ago, I remember that. I got a pager. Just be great at whatever job they give you because it's more fun to be great than to like suck at it and say you don't want to do it. Just ace it for fun, you know? Right. And I would go to like mobile management meetings. And I remember, I'm going to tell a story. It's very similar to your style.
无论你做什么工作，在你通往目标的路上，都要做到最好。要做到最好。我成了美孚加油站的副经理。我还记得看那次采访。你是和黛安·索亚一起去的吗？对，对，对，对。大约25年前。30年前，我还记得那件事。我拿到了寻呼机。无论他们给你什么工作，都要把它做到极致，因为做到最好比做得一塌糊涂然后说你不想干要有趣得多。为了好玩也要把它做到极致，你知道吗？对。我会去参加美孚的管理层会议。我记得，我要讲一个故事。这和你的风格非常相似。
I was sitting at a meeting in a convention room with all of these mobile managers and there was a woman who was giving a speech to all the mobile managers and it was called Give Him the Pickle. And it was all based on if you're working at a deli and someone comes up and says,
我当时坐在会议室的一个会议桌旁，和所有这些美孚经理在一起，有一位女士正在对所有的美孚经理发表演讲，主题叫做“给他们腌黄瓜”（Give Him the Pickle）。这完全是基于这样的理念：如果你在熟食店工作，有人走过来问：
can I have an extra pickle? Don't charge them for another pickle. Give them the pickle. That's a cool lesson to learn from pumping gas and makes up for how stupid you get from inhaling the fuse. Give him the extra pickle. Give him the pickle. Yep. And if they like it, give them the second one for free.
“我能多要一根腌黄瓜吗？”不要为另一根黄瓜收他们的钱。把腌黄瓜给他们。从加油中学到这一课真是个很酷的教训，而且这弥补了你因吸入废气而变傻的程度。多给他们一根腌黄瓜。给他们腌黄瓜。是的。如果他们喜欢，第二根免费送给他们。
So, how old were you? Wait, how old were you actually picked up a guitar and what made, was it really back to the future? You're like, I want to be Marty McFly. Yeah, I saw it back to the future and whatever that thing was, which was that moment of like, comeuppance, you know? Like, that always meant something to me. And then I would like go to tag sales. We called them tag sales in the northeast or garage sales. and I'd buy a guitar
所以，你当时多大？等等，你究竟是什么时候拿起吉他的？是什么让你产生这种想法的，真的是因为《回到未来》吗？你当时想成为马蒂·麦克弗莱吗？对，我看了《回到未来》，无论那是什么东西，那就是那种“扬眉吐气”的时刻，你知道吗？这种感觉对我来说一直意义重大。然后我会去逛旧货市场。我们在东北部把它们叫做旧货市场或车库旧货出售。我会买一把吉他
My mom buy me guitar for like $2 and like the first four guitars never had all six strings on them but then I'll never forget the day I had a guitar with all six strings because that was all of the strings and then I could really go off and running and I just saw the
我妈妈给我买了一把大概2美元的吉他，前四把吉他从来没有凑齐过全部六根弦。但我永远不会忘记我拥有一把六根弦全备的吉他的那一天，因为那是所有的弦，然后我就可以真正地大展身手了。我当时就看到了……
I saw the geometry of the thing and I went got it and it wasn't that I knew how to play the guitar but I knew how I was going to and I just so quickly went and took things like rocks from the don't know it pile
我看到了那东西的几何结构，然后我掌握了。并不是说我知道怎么弹吉他，而是我知道我将如何去弹。我很快就去把诸如“不知道”堆里的东西，
and put it into the know it pile. But it wasn't because I worked harder. I just looked at that thing and I went, I got it. Did you self-teach, did you just like start making noises? Yeah, I was lucky. If you're ever, anyone out there, if you're going to give your kid a guitar, don't give them lessons for like a couple weeks.
放进了“知道”堆里。但这并不是因为我更努力。我只是看着那个东西，心想，我懂了。你是自学的吗？你就是开始制造噪音吗？对，我很幸运。如果你，如果任何人，如果你要给你的孩子一把吉他，不要让他们在前几周就去上课。
Yeah. Just go looking. Go looking around. Play around. Just see, because I still see the guitar neck the way I did when I first looked at it. And then I started taking it. I started taking lessons. And then the guitar instructor,
对。去自己摸索。周围玩玩。看看，因为我至今看待吉他琴颈的方式，依然和刚开始看它时一样。然后我才开始学习。我开始上课。然后吉他老师，
they used to cut it in half, 30 minutes, it would be 15 and 15. The first 15 minutes would be learning from the book and the second 15 minutes was like, bring in a song, and the guitar teacher will show you that song. And before long, it was just all bring in a song. And it was all show me everything.
他们过去常常把它切成两半，30分钟的课分成15分钟和15分钟。前15分钟是跟着书本学，后15分钟则是，带一首歌来，吉他老师会教你这首歌。没过多久，就全变成带歌来了。变成教我所有的东西。
And I could just, I'd go home and I'd come back and I'd do it and I'd go, give me more, give me more. And I just loved it. And I loved it. And then, I know, you're trying to get me to taper down with this story. and I'm almost there. No, no, no.
然后我可以，我回家去，然后回来，做完之后我会说，再给我点，再给我点。我就是喜欢它。我太喜欢了。然后，我知道，你想让我用这个故事作结。我快说完了。不，不，不。
I'm just, I'm, I'm, I'm truly... Sean, you loved it past tense. Were you like that? Sean, were you like that with the piano? Honestly, would you? I went through the face. I started at five years old, literally came home from kindergarten.
我只是，我，我，我真的……肖恩，你是过去式地喜欢它。你当时也是这样吗？肖恩，你弹钢琴时也是这样吗？老实说，是吗？我经历过那个阶段。我5岁开始学，简直是刚从幼儿园放学回家。
My mom was like, do you want to take piano lessons? I literally said, I'm not doing anything else. Why not? And she lived across the street and I started taking piano lessons. And then as I got older, all the adults in my life
我妈就问：“你想学钢琴吗？”我简直说：“我什么都不做，就学这个。”为什么不呢？她就住在街对面，我开始学钢琴。然后随着年龄的增长，我生活中的所有成年人
kept saying, gosh, you know, you're taking piano lessons? I wish I would have stayed with that. I wish, or violin lessons, or whatever lessons they took. Over and over again, all the adults would say, I wish I stuck with it. And so I turned that messaging. I turned all those regrets into motivation.
都在不停地说：“天哪，你知道吗，你在学钢琴？我真希望当年坚持下来了。”我希望，或者小提琴课，或者他们上的任何课程。一次又一次，所有的成年人都说，我真希望当年坚持下来了。所以我把这些信息转化了。我把所有的遗憾都转化成了动力。
And so I was like, there must be something to that. I wonder if I just stick with it, like everybody's saying they wish they did, it might pay off. And I might get respect for it because they gave up on it. So I don't know why it's stuck in it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I have the door building.
所以我当时想，这其中一定有什么道理。我想如果我像每个人说的那样坚持下来，他们希望自己曾坚持过，也许就会有所回报。而且我可能会因此赢得尊重，因为他们都放弃了。所以我不知道为什么我能坚持下来。对。对。对，我有建门筑屋的……
Connecting with an instrument is like flying. Every time I've tried to teach myself how to play guitar, I can't get past how much it hurts my fingers. I know. So I stop every time. It hurts, man. Yet you'll watch a series for nine episodes because someone says it gets good on the 10th.
与乐器建立连接就像在飞翔。每次我试图自学弹吉他时，我都无法克服它对手指造成的疼痛。我懂。所以我每次都放弃。太疼了，兄弟。然而，你会因为别人说某部剧到第10集才变精彩，而去连续看9集。
The things we'll stick with and the things we won't. I know. But also you have to get a guitar that's set up right. sometimes people's first guitars have been in attics and stuff. Do they make soft strings? They make soft strings. My 14-year-olds here, he's up there and he started playing bass a couple years ago.
我们总是能坚持某些事情，却对另一些事情半途而废。我知道。但你还得买一把调校正确的吉他。有时候人们的第一把吉他一直在阁楼之类的阴暗地方。他们生产软弦吗？他们生产软弦。我14岁的儿子在这儿，他在那儿，他几年前开始弹贝斯。
Now he taught himself to play guitar, and he's making music in his room. You knew that, I told you that. Abel, where are you at, Abe? He's up there somewhere. Base strings, that's easier on the fingers. Those are bigger strings. It's like a gateway drug to guitars in a way, right?
现在他自学了弹吉他，正在自己的房间里创作音乐。你知道的，我跟你说过。阿贝尔，你在哪儿，阿贝尔？他大概在那儿的某个地方。贝斯弦，对手指更友好一些。那些是粗弦。从某种意义上说，这就像是通往吉他世界的入门毒品，对吧？
Yeah, I mean, sometimes it's whatever the band needs. Sorry, buddy, I don't mean that. But it's all about whether the guitar is set up. You're going to pay for that later. It's only four strings, too, right? Yes. When did you start having panic attacks? Oh, my God.
对，我的意思是，有时取决于乐队需要什么。抱歉，老兄，我不是那个意思。但这完全取决于吉他是否调校好了。你以后会为此付出代价的。而且也只有四根弦，对吧？是的。你是什么时候开始有恐慌发作的？哦，天哪。
Boy. Nice, smooth. Because I have, I had them too. The worst host in the history podcast. No, listen to me. Because I had them too. Like 20 seconds ago. Yeah.
天呐。好极了，真顺畅。因为我也有，我以前也有。播客历史上最糟糕的主持人。不，听我说。因为我以前也有。就在20秒前。对。
Because I had them too, and then I get aphib, which is cardiac aerhythmia with me, which you have. I have as well. And do you know when you're in it or no? Okay, is there a doctor in the house just in case? They both seem like they're ready to pop. Yeah, because I had to go to the emergency room a lot to get cardiovert. Is that what you had to do? I didn't have to do cardioversion.
因为我以前也有，然后我得了房颤，也就是心脏心律失常，这也是你有的。我也有。你知道自己什么时候在发作吗？好吧，这屋里有医生以防万一吗？他们俩看起来都随时准备爆粗口。对，因为我不得不经常去急诊室做心脏复律。那是你必须做的吗？我没有做过心脏复律。
So let's just get super esoteric here. When I was 17, I had aphib, paracismal loan, aphib. Sure, sure. And I got out of it with a digitalist. It's an antirthmic. Yeah, I tried that. It doesn't work. Got out of there for me.
那我们就来聊点非常高深的话题吧。我17岁时得了房颤，阵发性特发性房颤。确实，确实。我是靠地高辛（digitalis）缓过来的。这是一种抗心律失常药。对，我试过那个。不管用。帮我摆脱了困境。
And it's not, it's not fatal for most people. It is a slight risk of stroke. Right. But it's just a nuisance. Right. And it keeps me honest because I'm on a daily, I'm on Fleckinide 50 million. I was a day. You talk to the TV at home. This is, you have...
而且这，对大多数人来说并不是致命的。它有轻微的中风风险。对。但这只是个烦人的毛病。对。它让我保持诚实，因为我每天都在吃。我在吃50毫克氟卡尼（Flecainide）。我以前每天吃。你在家里对着电视机说话。这是，你有……
I wait goodbye to the ladies in the view. I'm like, goodbye. Yeah. As they say goodbye. Wait a minute. Me too. I tried Fleckonide, but then I just take it as needed. Yeah. Okay. I take it because I have lots of PACs or premature atrial complexes and hundreds a day
我向《观点》（The View）节目里的女士们挥手说再见。我说，再见。对。当她们说再见时。等一下。我也是。我试过氟卡尼，但后来我只是按需服用。对。好吧。我服用是因为我有大量的PAC（房性早搏）或者说房性期前收缩，一天有几百次，
if I'm not on fleckonide. And sometimes I'll take a metoprolol, which is a beta block. I'll take 50 milligrams of metopalal. Same metropelal, yeah. This reminds me of a TV show idea I have. And it's about a doctor who's a vampire, but he never went to medical school. He just lived so long that everything under the sun happened to him.
如果我不吃氟卡尼的话。有时候我会吃美托洛尔（metoprolol），这是一种β受体阻滞剂。我会吃50毫克的美托洛尔。一样的美托洛尔，对。这让我想起了一个我有的电视剧创意。讲的是一个吸血鬼医生，但他从未去过医学院。他只是活得太久了，以至于太阳底下的所有事都在他身上发生过。
So he just knows everything because he's lived like 800 years. And he's always trying to break in to drink the blood. I mean, we have that. We have the blood thing. We have these always sneaking around the different floors. And I really think I hit it out of the park with the name just Dr. Vampire MD. And like just come out with it. And I think if you're driving down sunset to go back to wherever you guys are, you know, on the west side,
所以他什么都知道，因为他活了大概800岁。他总是试图溜进来吸血。我的意思是，我们有那个。我们有吸血鬼的梗。我们这些总是在不同楼层鬼鬼祟祟的人。我真的觉得我给这个剧起的名字绝了，就叫《吸血鬼医生医学博士》（Dr. Vampire MD）。就像直接说出来一样。我觉得如果你正开着车沿着日落大道去你们这些家伙要去的地方，你知道的，在西区，
and you see a lit up sign over the saddle ranch, this is Dr. Vampire MD, that you'd be like, I would check that out. Absolutely. I would totally check that out. Will you write the theme song? Yes. Wait, why don't you have hair on your arms? Simply the worst.
看到萨多牧场（Saddle Ranch）上方亮起的一个招牌，写着这是“吸血鬼医生医学博士”，你就会想，我会去看看那个。绝对的。我绝对会去看看。你愿意写主题曲吗？愿意。等等，为什么你胳膊上没有毛？简直糟糕透顶。
This is the worst. This is the worst. Simply worse than all the worst. Terrible. All the worst. Sean and I have both lost the hair on our shins from socks. I don't have hair here. I used to make fun of Jeffrey Tambor for that.
这太糟糕了。这太糟糕了。简直比所有糟糕的事还要糟糕。太可怕了。所有的糟糕。肖恩和我都因为袜子的摩擦把小腿上的毛给磨掉了。我这里没有毛。我以前还拿这个嘲笑过杰弗里·塔伯（Jeffrey Tambor）。
But he was like, oh, you wait, you'll get old enough, you lose it. So you're saying you lose hair on the legs? Yeah, from socks. Like on the inside I got hair. Outside, like a biker. Yeah, I'm not a very, I don't, I can't grow a beef. I'm not very... Same.
但他当时说，哦，你等着，等你年纪大点，它就掉光了。所以你是说你腿上的毛会掉光？对，从袜子里掉的。比如内侧我有毛。外侧，像个机车骑手。对，我不是很……我长不出胡子。我不是很……一样。
Alabaster all the way. Yeah. You and I are smooth. Yeah. We're smooth. We're smooth. We're smooth jazz. Yeah.
从头到脚都是雪白。对。你和我都是光溜溜的。对。我们很光滑。我们很光滑。我们是柔和的爵士乐。对。
John, whose body was a Wonderland? Oh. I had that. I can tell you, and I think I've told people this much. It was your first girlfriend. Yeah, it was my first girlfriend. Oh my God, he's mocking my answer. The worst host.
约翰，谁的身体是一处仙境？哦。我有过那首歌。我可以告诉你，我想我已经跟很多人说过这个了。那是你的初女友。对，那是我的初女友。哦天哪，他在嘲笑我的回答。最糟糕的主持人。
...mocking my answer. I've never had anybody mock an answer. I would have sweetened it up and put something in you hadn't heard. No, okay, sorry, go ahead. My first girlfriend. Get to it, mayor. Get to this question.
……在嘲笑我的回答。我从来没遇到过会嘲笑别人回答的人。我会把它说得好听点，加入一些你没听过的内容。不，好吧，抱歉，你继续。我的初女友。快说吧，市长。回答这个问题。
The first of this total setup because you asked me the question. Actually, what you're doing is making fun of him for asking. That's right, that's right. That's right. But I did have on here, you have a high profile dating history.
这完全是个套路，因为是你先问我这个问题的。实际上，你这么做是在取笑他提问。没错，没错。没错。但我这里确实记着，你有一段备受瞩目的约会史。
Do we talk about it or not talk about it? Here, here's why I don't... And that had to do with it. I would talk about me if it related to me. Sure. But I am older now. It's been a very long time since I mean, I have my own
我们是该聊这个还是不该聊？听着，这就是为什么我不……这和那有关。如果是关于我的，我会聊自己。当然。但我现在年纪大了。自我……以来已经过了很长时间了，我有我自己的
situation from that. I stay inside the house. Aren't I a good boy, America? I'm not dating anybody. Aren't I good? Are you single right now? I'm a single person. I'm a catch. Would you, would you, would you like, do you do you have dreams
那种情况。我待在家里。我不是个好男孩吗，美国？我没有跟任何人约会。我难道不好吗？你现在单身吗？我是一个单身人士。我很抢手。你，你，你，喜欢，你有没有梦想
of being a husband, a father? Absolutely. Yeah? Absolutely. It's not easy. It's not easy for John Mayer to date. In all seriousness, like, what are you going to do? Like, it's tough to meet people. No, but I'll tell you, it's a very good, it's a very good filtration
成为一个丈夫、一个父亲？绝对有。是吗？绝对有。这可不容易。约翰·梅尔要约会可不容易。说真的，你会怎么做？要遇到合适的人很难。不，但我告诉你，这是一个非常好的、
system of selecting who's right. So if, if it's not easy, then that means when the right person comes along, well, then that's easy because of how not easy it is until you meet the right. But let me ask you about what's right and what's wrong for a girlfriend versus a wife,
筛选合适人选的过滤系统。所以，如果这不容易，那就意味着当对的人出现时，那就会变得很容易，因为在遇到对的人之前，这一切是多么的不容易。不过让我问你关于女朋友和妻子的区别，
versus somebody that you might have a child with. Are you looking for something different now than you were, say, 10 years ago. Because they're one and the same. I would not date someone if it didn't have the upward mobility of becoming a marriage. Right, so don't marry a girlfriend, perhaps, said differently. But I don't understand.
以及和你可能会共同育有孩子的对象之间的区别。你现在寻找的东西和大约10年前相比有什么不同吗？因为它们本质上是一回事。如果一段关系没有发展成婚姻的上升空间，我是不会和对方约会的。对，所以不要把女朋友娶回家，也许换个说法是这样。我不明白。
Wouldn't you always marry your girlfriend? Well, I do. I think there's a difference. Explain it. Well, I think... You know what they say? Never marry your girlfriend. Well, but...
难道你不想永远娶你的女朋友吗？好吧，我愿意。我认为这有区别。解释一下。好吧，我认为……你知道他们怎么说吗？永远不要娶你的女朋友。好吧，但是……
It feels like... They never said it. This is going to be... Hi Amanda You know what they say They say be friends with your best friend No no John let him keep digging please Babe, should I put the shovel down?
感觉……他们才没这么说过。这将会是……嗨，阿曼达。你知道他们怎么说吗？他们说要和你的好朋友做朋友。不，不，约翰，让他继续挖坑吧，求你了。宝贝，我是不是该放下铲子了？
Oh no I do think that You guys come in separate cars? No damn it But you know You might make a choice To date somebody That you think Oh well this should be a fun girlfriend
哦不，我确实觉得……你们俩是坐两辆车来的吗？不，该死。但你知道的……你可能会做出一个选择，去和某个人约会，
that it doesn't really have legs to go at distance, but... All my girlfriends have had legs. It's something, I mean, I... Good for you. Good for you, dude. Yeah. So far, I don't disagree. You gotta have standards, you know? It just happens to be.
你觉得，哦，这应该是个有趣的女朋友，虽然它并不具备长远发展的潜力，但是……我所有的女朋友都有潜力。怎么说呢，我……真为你高兴。真为你高兴，老兄。Yeah.目前为止，我并不反驳。你得有标准，你知道吗？事情就是这样发生的。
I'm not looking on... But, Jay, keep going, though. Laugh it up, giggles. You're on a... You want a dating site right now? I'm not. Every girlfriend would be a potential wife at this point. I am 47, which...
我不是在寻找……但是，杰伊，继续说吧。笑吧，尽情傻笑吧。你正在……你现在想上约会网站吗？我没有。在这个阶段，每个女朋友都可能是潜在的妻子。我47岁了，这……
Oh, you're young. So at this point... Same. Same. Do you think... You're older than 47. Do you still think 47 is young? Is there something about 47 compared to 63?
哦，你还年轻。所以在这个阶段……一样。一样。你觉得……你比47岁大。你还觉得47岁年轻吗？47岁和63岁相比有什么区别吗？
Yeah. No. Yeah. It is young. Yeah, so... 45. But... So, however difficult it is, is how easy it will be to identify someone who's right.
对。没有。对。这很年轻。对，所以……45岁。但是……所以，无论有多难，就能有多容易地辨认出谁是对的人。
I think that's how I look at it. Well, yeah, with age comes, you know, the ability to reflect on your past and not repeat the same mistakes. So when you enter a new relationship, you are hopefully, wiser and all of those things. Can I tell you something? I'm going to be really honest. Just between us. Please just say it's all a fucking crapshoot.
我想我是这么看的。好吧，是的，随着年龄的增长，你会拥有反思过去并不重复同样错误的能力。所以当你进入一段新的关系时，你希望自己能变得更聪明，以及所有这些事情。我能告诉你一件事吗？我要说实话。就在我们之间。请直说这一切其实就是一场该死的碰运气。
I am very well behaved. I believe that being well behaved. Like I really care. I've developed really the best parts of me. I'm very well behaved. I treat people really well.
我表现得非常好。我相信表现好……就像我真的很在乎一样。我已经把我身上最好的部分开发出来了。我表现得很好。我对待别人真的很好。
I'm honest. I'm sincere. I'm not sarcastic. And I don't know that people know this about me. And so I think that when people come into a dating situation with me. They think I'm going to be snappy and quick and sarcastic, but I'm not. Wait, is that bad?
我很诚实。我很真诚。我一点也不刻薄。我不知道人们是否了解我这一点。所以我认为当人们带着某种交友心态来接触我时，他们会觉得我应该是个言语刻薄、反应敏捷、喜欢挖苦人的人，但我并不是。等等，这不好吗？
Well, listen, you guys are really given yes and a run for its money out here. But I'm very well-behaved, and the thing is you have to be well-behaved. Was it always that way? No. Okay. Because you're a rock star, and if I'm a girl thinking about dating you, I think, well, this could be a
好吧，听着，你们这些家伙真的是把“对”发挥到了极致。但我表现得很好，关键是你必须表现得很好。以前一直是这样吗？不是。好吧。因为你是个摇滚明星，如果我是一个正考虑和你约会的女孩，我会想，这可能会是一个
challenge. Yeah, I mean, see, hell have no fury or like, maybe not. Nothing is worse than someone who believes they're doing right and they're not. Like that's, most assholes in dating
挑战。是的，我的意思是，看，没有什么比地狱更愤怒的了，或者可能不是。没有什么比一个自以为在做好事却并非如此的人更糟糕了。就像那个，约会时大多数混蛋
are such assholes because if they would pass a lie detector test that they mean well. They're good at being assholes. You can mean well and be terribly misbehaved. And that's the kind of trap you get. This is call her daddy. right?
都是彻头彻尾的混蛋，因为如果让他们通过测谎仪，他们会觉得自己是好意。他们很擅长当混蛋。你可以心怀善意，却行为极其恶劣。这就是你陷入的陷阱。这里是呼叫她的爸爸。对吧？
Yeah, yeah. This is where we are? So I am very well-behaved, and I've never articulated this before, so forgive me if it sounds strict. I expect good, like great behavior turns me on. I fixed, like high wattage,
是啊，是啊。我们这是在哪儿？所以我表现得很好，我以前从没表达过这一点，所以如果听起来很严格，请原谅我。我期待美好的、就像伟大的行为能让我兴奋。我固定了，就像高瓦数，
and I'm not saying anything about just in general, high-wadage, Hollywood, zing it at you, kind of thing. That was interesting when I was young and now, like, fucking being well-being. behaved is the hottest shit in the world. What's your version of... Like good sleep hygiene, table manners?
我不是在说什么只是总体而言，高瓦数的，好莱坞式的，对你大喊大叫的那种。当我年轻的时候这很有趣，而现在，他妈的，表现良好是世界上最酷的事情。你的版本是什么……比如良好的睡眠卫生，餐桌礼仪？
If you... You know what I would say it is? Responding to insecurity in a sincere way. Yeah. Amen. That's good. But I do have... Well, the ability to be vulnerable, too, is a big thing. And that's what you get when you get older,
如果你……你知道我会说它是什么吗？以真诚的方式回应不安全感。是的。阿门。真不错。但我确实有……嗯，脆弱的能力也是一件大事。这就是你年长时得到的，
because you don't give a shit. You're like, hey, this is who I am. So what ended up happened... You're right. But I think that younger people need to get a head start on being more vulnerable. Being sarcastically invulnerable and apathetic is a really good healing mechanism
因为你根本不在乎。你会觉得，嘿，这就是我。所以最终发生的事情……你是对的。但我认为年轻人需要抢先一步变得更加脆弱。讽刺地表现得刀枪不入且无动于衷，是一种极好的疗愈机制
to get over the past breakup. It is a great way to get over somebody is to go out with your girls and take a couple pictures for your dating site where you're like licking a knife, you know, whatever. I get it. I get that.
来走出过去的分手。走出某段感情的好方法，就是和你的闺蜜们出去，为你的约会网站拍几张照片，比如舔刀子之类的，随便什么。我懂。我懂。
But you can't carry that into your necks. I fear that there's a generation of people, men and women. who have decided to come into relationships in a very inflexible, sarcastic. Vulnerability is the shit. Yeah, it's the best. Leave yourself so vulnerable
但你不能把这带到你的脖子上。我担心有一代人，无论男女，他们决定以非常不灵活、讽刺的方式进入恋爱关系。脆弱才是王道。是的，这是最好的。让自己变得如此脆弱
that you could die if someone said the wrong thing to you. And just die a thousand times and drive home and do all those farts in the car and get home and go, well, we tried. I know that's the route to a quicker, better thing. Just be vulnerable. I want to get to your career because I have tremendous...
以至于如果有人对你说了错误的话，你就会死掉。然后死上一千次，开车回家，在车里放各种屁，到家后说，好吧，我们尽力了。我知道这是通往更快、更好结果的途径。只要变得脆弱。我想谈谈你的事业，因为我有巨大的……
I do. I want to get back to my career too. Yeah. I did have something about the sleep that you take magnesium baths. I don't even know what that is. Where did you get... It's magnesium baths.
我确实有。我也想回到我的事业上来。是的。我确实有关于你洗镁浴的睡眠问题。我都不知道那是什么。你在哪弄的……这是镁浴。
John, are you late for something? Are you in a rush? No, I don't want to... I don't want to overstay our welcome with our friends. I thought you got this in chat GPT and you would say, chat GPT, are you sure about the magnesium bath thing
约翰，你有什么事迟到了吗？你在赶时间吗？不，我不想……我不想赖在我们的朋友这里不受欢迎。我以为你是从聊天GPT上看到的，你会说，聊天GPT，你确定镁浴这事吗
with John? And it would say, you're right. I can't find exactly where I found there was a magnesium bath. I tried looking. I love what Chadji Pate is like, fuck, you got me. All right, we don't talk about it. No, so, but I do have,
和约翰一起？然后它会说，你说的对。我找不到我究竟是在哪儿看到有镁浴这东西的。我试着找了。我很喜欢查吉·佩特那种，操，你抓到我了。好吧，我们不谈这个。不，所以，但我确实有，
speaking about being vulnerable, if I can be vulnerable with you right now, that I do have, from one musician to another, tremendous respect for you. Take it easy. I do. I just think, I know so many of your songs. The first one, you know,
说到脆弱，如果我现在能对你敞开心扉，作为一个音乐人对另一个音乐人，我对你有着极大的敬意。别客气。我确实有。我只是觉得，我知道你那么多的歌。第一首，你知道的，
The first one I think most people knew you from is, I want to run through the halls of my high school. I want to scream at the top of my loss. Yeah, I love that. I love that song. Anyway, but go back to me. You released. Isn't it funny that singers who also just talk,
我想大多数人知道你的第一首歌是，我想跑过我高中的大厅。我想声嘶力竭地尖叫。是的，我喜欢那个。我喜欢那首歌。不管怎样，回到我身上。你发行了。歌手们也只是说话，是不是很搞笑，
but you know the whole time they're talking, they could be singing? Yeah. I always, when I was younger, I would watch people, I'd be like, that guy's talking, but he's also singing. And I feel like sometimes I want to show people, It's like, this is me talking, this is me talking, this is me talking. I'm kind of moving into singing now. I'm kind of moving into singing now.
但你知道他们说话的整个过程，他们本可以唱歌？是的。我总是，当我年轻的时候，我会看着人们，我会想，那家伙在说话，但他也在唱歌。我觉得有时我想向人们展示，就像，这是我在说话，这是我在说话，这是我在说话。我现在有点转向唱歌了。我现在有点转向唱歌了。
I want to run through the halls of my... I'm coming back to, but now I'm coming back into talking, but now I'm talking again. Now I'm talking again. But at any moment I wanted to, I could go, what's to bring me down? But I can talk again. Yes.
我想跑过我的……我又回来了，但现在我又回到了说话状态，但现在我又在说话了。现在我又在说话了。但在任何我想的时候，我都可以说，有什么能打倒我？但我可以再次说话。是的。
But I can talk again. But here's the thing. Isn't that weird? Yeah, I'm going to ask you to sing at the end of the show here, and then you're going to feel really uncomfortable. Wait, are you in a question? Because I want to ask you about your musicianship.
但我可以再次说话。但问题是。这不是很奇怪吗？是的，等下节目结束时我会请你唱歌，然后你会感到非常不自在。等等，你在问问题吗？因为我想问你的音乐造诣。
So when you joined... Dead in company? Yeah, I'm making sure you didn't say Grateful Dead. So, I'm not a deadhead, but I've loved the Grateful Dead for many years. I've only gone to, like, I went to like 10 shows, but I'm not a deadhead. But I watched you in an interview talking about learning the songs and how quickly you learned all those songs. It is bananas.
所以当你加入……死者与公司？是的，我得确保你没说感恩而死。所以，我不是死忠粉，但我多年来一直很喜欢感恩而死乐队。我只去过，比如，我去过大约10场演出，但我不是死忠粉。但我看你的一次采访，谈到学习这些歌曲以及你学得有多快。这太疯狂了。
Can you tell us a little bit about that process if you guys don't know? Yeah, so I was falling in love with the music of Grateful Dead. Like falling in love. If I hadn't joined the band or met Bob Weir and Mickey Hart and Bill Kreutzman, I would have just fallen into that anyway. And it's actually funny,
如果你各位不知道的话，能跟我们讲讲这个过程吗？是的，所以我当时正爱上感恩而死乐队的音乐。就像坠入爱河一样。如果我没有加入乐队或者遇到鲍勃·维尔、米奇·哈特和比尔·克鲁茨曼，我也会自己迷上这个。而且其实挺搞笑的，
the way I met them was through a mutual friend Don Was, producer extraordinaire Don Was. Who said, come up and I know how much you love Grateful Dead right now, come up and meet the guys. and I was just telling them how much their music meant to me. And they were like, what do you do in March 7th? And so I was like, wherever you need me because they were looking at putting a band together.
我遇到他们是通过一个共同的朋友唐·沃斯，金牌制作人唐·沃斯。他说，上来吧，我知道你现在有多爱感恩而死，上来见见大家。我当时只是告诉他们他们的音乐对我的意义有多大。他们问，你3月7号在做什么？于是我说，你们需要我去哪儿都行，因为他们当时正考虑组建一个乐队。
So it was really fascinating because as I was falling in love with the music, I would just learn how to play it on the guitar. And I made a binder. And the binder had a bunch of, you know, the tablature or she, you know, whatever the manuscript paper was and I would just write the song down and I would just do a song a day.
所以这真的很有趣，因为当我坠入音乐爱河时，我就会自己学着在吉他上弹奏它。我做了一个文件夹。文件夹里有一堆，你知道的，吉他谱或者乐谱，你知道的，不管是哪种稿纸，我就会把歌写下来，一天写一首歌。
But I was in love with this song a day. So I would just, I took like six months off and learned how to play those songs in my house. But I mean, it's, how many songs is it? I mean, I think we played like 150 songs. It's fucking incredible. And you learn them, you learn them all like in a short amount of time. But you do this with lines, Will. Yeah, it's a little bit different, man.
但我是一天到晚都沉浸在对这首歌的热爱中。所以我请了大约六个月的假，在家里学会了弹奏那些歌。但我的意思是，这是，有多少首歌？我的意思是，我想我们弹了大约150首歌。这他妈太不可思议了。而且你学会了它们，你在很短的时间内把它们全学会了。但你是用台词做到这一点的，威尔。是的，这有点不同，老兄。
How so? I couldn't do it. I couldn't look at a... I say that too. I say lines, it's like singing. Because if you do a play, or you have to do the same lines over and over again, you have to do the same lines over and over again, you have to do the same lines over. It's like a song.
怎么说？我做不到。我做不到看着……我也是这么说的。我说台词，就像唱歌一样。因为如果你演一出戏，或者你必须一遍又一遍地重复同样的台词，你必须一遍又一遍地重复同样的台词，你必须一遍又一遍地重复同样的台词。这就像一首歌。
The geometry is already there. It's not like I have to make a new map for every song. And I'm already like visualizing where the music goes anyway. So it's kind of, it's easier than you might think to just place the... Think of it like a cork board with like index cards or something. You go, okay, those are there. Or like dancers who can have like a two-minute thing and someone can go, take out that step in bar 12.
几何结构已经存在了。并不是说我必须为每首歌制作一张新地图。而且我已经在脑海中可视化音乐的走向了。所以这某种程度上，比你想象的要容易，只要把……把它想象成一个带有索引卡之类的软木板。你会说，好吧，那些在那里。或者像舞者，他们可以有一两分钟的舞蹈，然后有人会说，去掉第12小节的那个动作。
And they can just... It's like it's in innate language. and if I had to learn how to do it and it wasn't in me, I wouldn't be able to do it. Are you one of the positions that... Did you ever learn how to read music? No, but I could read a chord chart, but I can't read music.
他们就可以直接……这就像是一种与生俱来的语言，如果我不得不学习如何做到这一点，而它不是我骨子里的东西，我就做不到。你是那种……你从来没学过识谱吗？没有，但我能看懂和弦谱，但我不会识谱。
That's amazing. Yeah. But if I had, I don't know that I would have even used that skill that much in pop music. You know, you've written... So many songs, there's... By the way, I love...
太惊人了。是的。但如果我学会了，我不知道我在流行音乐中是否会经常使用这项技能。你知道，你写过……这么多歌，有……顺便说一句，我喜欢……
What is it called? All we ever do is say goodbye. I love that song so much. What's album was that on? That's on... That's on battle studies. And it's funny because as a writer, you can put a song out and then kind of get down about it.
那首歌叫什么来着？我们所做的一切就是说再见。我太喜欢那首歌了。那是哪张专辑里的？那是……那是《战斗研究》（Battle Studies）。有趣的是，作为一名作家，你可以发布一首歌曲，然后对它感到有点沮丧。
Oh, I think it's kind of this. And then years later, you listen back to it as someone who wouldn't or couldn't write that song today. And so you hear it for the first time. And I heard it for the first time not long ago after years of not listening to it. And I was like, oh, this is very nice. But when you listen back to it, do you remember where you were? And I don't mean necessarily physically,
哦，我觉得有点像这样。然后多年后，你以一个今天不会或不能写出这首歌的人的身份回听它。所以你听到了全新的感觉。不久前，在多年没有听它之后，我第一次听了它，我当时想，哦，这很好听。但是当你回听它的时候，你还记得你在哪里吗？我指的并不一定是物理上的，
but where you were, what it meant to you in the moment, you're like, oh, like when you hear a lyric or you hear a certain note that you hit and you go like, oh, yeah, I remember why I did that. All of it. There's an emotional connection to it. All of it. It's very deep as I get older.
而是你在哪里，它在当时对你意味着什么，你会想，哦，就像当你听到一句歌词或听到你击中的某个音符时，你会说，哦，是的，我记得我为什么那样做。全都是。它有一种情感联系。全都是。随着我年龄的增长，这变得非常深沉。
It really is. I'll tell you why, like, I don't know how to deal with it sometimes because I'll listen back to things and be so... And this is not arrogance because I'm not the same person. I can't do that anymore. Like you're not the same person you were when you wrote letters to boyfriends
真的。我告诉你为什么，有时候我不知道该怎么处理它，因为我回听这些东西会感到非常……这不是傲慢，因为我不再是同一个人了。我做不到了。就像你不再是写情书给男朋友时的那个自己
or when you wrote in your diary. So I can look at it preserved in amber as this thing and I, it's very deep, but profound because I appreciate it. I can't believe that I did that, but I'm not that anymore. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It doesn't belong to me, even though everyone would say it does. I go, but those cells that made that thought
或者当你在日记里写东西的时候。所以我可以把它保存在琥珀中，作为一个这样的东西来观察，这非常深奥，但也很深刻，因为我很感激。我不敢相信我做到了，但我已经不再是那样了。是的，是的，是的。它不属于我，尽管每个人都说它属于我。我说，但是那些产生那个想法的细胞
and the person I was when I was that vulnerable or I was in that particular way and I didn't understand the world and I want to be able to say hey that's my song but I listen back to it and there's a sadness to not having it. It's really hard to explain it.
以及当我如此脆弱或处于那种特殊状态时的我，我不理解这个世界，我想能够说，嘿，那是我的歌，但我回听它时，却有一种没有它的悲伤。这真的很难解释。
But then John, they have a relationship with the song when they enjoy it or they say hey I really love that song it really spoke to me. I was going through I was going through a breakup or somebody in my family died or whatever and they have a different emotional response to it
但随后，约翰，当他们享受这首歌时，或者他们说，嘿，我真的很喜欢那首歌，它真的触动了我，他们与这首歌建立了一种关系。我当时经历着……我正在经历分手，或者我家里的某个人去世了，等等，他们对此有不同的情感反应。
How does that hit you? That's great. Whatever it is to someone else is great. And I'm at that age now where people have lost people they used to go to shows with or people they used to listen to the music with. And it makes you more, it's such a deeper connection for people. It makes up for the times people go like,
这给你的触动是什么？这很好。对别人来说是什么样都很好。我现在到了这个年龄，人们失去了曾经一起去看演出的人，或者曾经一起听音乐的人。这让你觉得更深刻，对人们来说是如此深刻的联系。这弥补了人们说，
you were my high school crush. Does this happen to you guys? Yeah, yeah. I mean, you go, it's never happened. Oh, this is the one. This is the one. My 14-year-old self is freaking out right now. Yeah, right.
你曾是我高中的暗恋对象。这种事你们遇到过吗？是的，是的。我的意思是，你会说，这从未发生过。哦，就是这个。就是这个。我14岁的自己现在正抓狂呢。是的，没错。
And I go, so you're not. not. And the version that did is no longer here, and you're here representing a former verb, but we're all in, I'm... Do you feel like you're in a better place
然后我说，所以你不是。而那个做过这事的版本已经不在了，而你在这里代表一个过去的动词，但我们都在，我是……你觉得你现在比过去处于一个更好的状态
now than you were back then to write songs and music? Do you think you're better now? I bet you are. Great question. Thank you. I'm better... That's beautiful. Thank you. That's beautiful.
来写歌和音乐吗？你觉得你现在更好了吗？我敢打赌你是。好问题。谢谢。我更好……太美妙了。谢谢。太美妙了。
Thank you. This is actually, it's, yeah, I could help anyone with their song. I could help anyone make their song better because of the just pure experience of trying to write every song or every type of song that's ever existed. Right. It gets harder to write as you get older, but you're better when you do.
谢谢。这实际上是，是的，我可以帮任何人写歌。由于纯粹的尝试写过有史以来每一首歌或每一种歌的经验，我可以帮任何人把他们的歌写得更好。没错。随着年龄的增长，写作变得越来越难，但当你写的时候，你变得更好了。
And the reason it's harder to write is because you begin to answer questions that you've had your whole life. And you should, you shouldn't live in a constant state of raw nerves, you know. And so when I was younger, everything hurt and I could write. And I wanted to know, why does this hurt? I got to get this out. And as you get older, you have wisdom and you understand why. And you help other people who don't understand why something's happening.
写作变难的原因是，你开始回答你一生中一直在思考的问题。而且你应该这样，你不应该生活在不断紧张的状态中，你知道的。所以当我年轻的时候，一切都很痛，我能写。我想知道，为什么这会痛？我必须把这个发泄出来。随着年龄的增长，你有了智慧，你明白了为什么。你去帮助那些不明白为什么会发生某些事情的人。
And you can tell them what's coming up the road. So music comes from wanting to understand what's going on. And the more you understand what's going on, the less is to write, but when you catch one, the more experienced you are at, like, putting spin on the ball, baby. Have you ever written a song though that's been like really emotional and then you've
你可以告诉他们前头会有什么。所以音乐来自于想要了解正在发生的事情。你对正在发生的事情理解得越多，要写的东西就越少，但当你抓住灵感时，你就越有经验，就像给球加旋转一样，宝贝。不过你有没有写过一首歌，非常感人，然后你
had somebody important in your life and they hear it and they're like, hey, fuck, are we good? Like, is that about me? Is that about me? Like, what the hell? I thought everything was cool. We went on vacation last week and I was listening to the radio today. Yeah, it happened to me one time. Really?
生活中的重要人物听到了，他们会说，嘿，操，我们还好吗？那是以我为原型的吗？那是以我为原型的吗？搞什么鬼？我以为一切都挺好的。我们上周刚去度假，我今天在收音机里听到了。是的，我有过一次。真的吗？
Yeah. And were they right? Was it about them? It's actually, good questions will get the right answers because I can't, yeah, I had a song called Perfectly Lonely, and at the end of the bridge, it was like something about I have to thank the love so that went wrong to lead me to a love so strong, and she said, am I the love that went wrong? Am I the love that went wrong?
是的。他们猜对了吗？是以他们为原型的吗？其实，好问题会得到正确的答案，因为我不能，是的，我有一首歌叫《完美孤独》（Perfectly Lonely），在副歌桥段的结尾，有关于我必须感谢走过弯路的爱，才引领我走向如此坚定的爱，她说，我是那段走错的爱吗？我是那段走错的爱吗？
And I had to be like, no, you're not, it's just a song. That was the only time I think anyone ever said. But they were. But for the most part, I'm actually very... Yeah, I mean, that's what I thought. Now she knows. And it really was, it really was the love that went wrong. For the most part, my songs aren't bitter.
我不得不说，不，你不是，这只是一首歌。那是我认为唯一一次有人这么说。但他们确实是。但大部分时候，我其实非常……是的，我的意思是，这就是我所想的。现在她知道了。那确实是，那确实是那段走错的爱。大多数情况下，我的歌并不苦涩。
I don't write songs that are like, how dare you songs. What's that? What did you say? Oh. Heartbreak warfare, yeah. Yeah. Except that one. Latin's track inside my chest to keep me.
我不写那种“你怎么敢”的歌。什么？你刚才说什么？哦。心碎之战（Heartbreak Warfare），对。是的。除了那一个。拉丁赛道在我胸口支撑着我。
No computers. Isn't this amazing? It's so good. But I mean, I tell you, I'm freaking out that you're singing in front of me right now. It's really cool. Speaking weird. Speaking of which, what's that God damn piano. You're a 14-year-old self.
没有电脑。这不是很神奇吗？太棒了。但我的意思是，我告诉你，看到你在我面前唱歌，我快疯了。这太酷了。说到这个，该死的那架钢琴是什么。你14岁的自己。
No, I had one last question before I asked. If you want me to play something, I'll play something. I know I said it would. I do. Obviously. Before that, before you get it, last question, let's say you could form a super group of musicians that are alive. Who's in it?
不，在我提问之前我还有最后一个问题。如果你想让我弹点什么，我会弹的。我知道我刚才说过。我的确想。很明显。在此之前，在你得到它之前，最后一个问题，假设你可以组建一个由仍然在世的音乐人组成的超级乐团。里面都有谁？
And what's the name? Alive. Okay. Great answer. That is good. So, to me, my hero, like, like, real. Okay, there's people you say they're your hero. but there's people that you just lose it around.
名字叫什么？活着。好的。好回答。这很好。对我和我的偶像来说，就像，真的。好吧，有些人你说是你的偶像。但有些人会让你在他们面前方寸大乱。
And to me, Eddie Vedder, to me, that's it. That's it. Love him, yeah. Like, you got to understand. Like, you can play any, people play so many different things on a guitar.
对我和埃迪·韦德（Eddie Vedder）来说，就是这样。就是这样。爱他，是的。你看，你得明白。就像，你可以弹奏任何，人们在吉他上弹奏的东西太多了。
I should say, there's only so many things you could play on a guitar. His particular way of dropping in. Yeah, yeah. So I would just want to, it's a selfish thing. I'd want to be next to him making music. Yeah, yeah.
我应该说，你在吉他上能弹的东西就那么多。他那种独特的切入方式。是的，是的。所以我只是想，这是一件很自私的事。我想挨着他一起做音乐。是的，是的。
And luckily, I'd put people in the band that probably already played with it. Put Steve Jordan on the, drums, but Pino on the bass. Yeah, I love that. You know, I, because I obviously I knew you were coming on because you're my guest today, but I went bonkers with nerves because I was
幸运的是，我会把那些可能已经跟他合作过的人放进乐队里。让史蒂夫·乔丹（Steve Jordan）打鼓，皮诺（Pino）弹贝斯。是的，我喜欢这样。你知道，我，因为我显然知道你要来，因为你是我今天的嘉宾，但我紧张得快疯了，因为我在
practicing a couple of your songs because I wanted to play with you. But I can't because we didn't rehearse. No, no, no, I can't. You have to because I didn't rehearse. No, no. I don't know the chords and all that. But, I mean, I need sheet music. I can't read fake books and the court search. So, but if you weren't going to play, I was going
练习你的几首歌，因为我想跟你一起弹。但我不能，因为我们没有彩排。不，不，不，我不能。你必须去，因为我没有彩排。不，不。我不知道和弦什么的。但是，我的意思是，我需要简谱。我看不懂假书和和弦谱。但是，如果你不打算弹，我本打算
to bait you by playing something myself, but I'm glad you are, so I don't have to. So please, would you indulge us and play something. I just have to remember it. It's very nice of you, John. Yes, very nice of you. Very nice of you. Oh my God, there's so many. Can I play anything I want?
通过自己弹奏来引诱你，但我很高兴你要弹，所以我不用了。所以拜托，你能赏脸给我们弹点什么吗？我只是得想起来。你太好了，约翰。是的，你太好了。你太好了。天哪，有太多了。我可以弹任何我想弹的吗？
Yes, but I want to impress you. You're the one who brought me in. You're the one who sent the email. Well, I like... I wrote all those great questions. That one. I love all we ever do is say goodbye. I love all the hit...
可以，但我想给你留下深刻印象。你是把我请来的人。你是发邮件的那个人。嗯，我喜欢……我写了所有这些好问题。那一个。我喜欢我们所做的一切就是说再见。我喜欢所有的热门……
I love the first one. I can't remember the name, but I know all the words. I want to run with my halls in high school. of such things? Yeah. I mean, you probably don't want to play that. I don't know. I mean, it's... Could you? Let him play what the hell he wants. Yeah, play whatever you want. I want you to play what you want. I'll tell you what. You call it out. I'll play a little bit of it.
我喜欢第一首。我不记得名字了，但我知道所有的歌词。我想跑过我高中的大厅。我想声嘶力竭地尖叫。有这种事吗？是的。我的意思是，你可能不想弹那个。我不知道。我的意思是，这是……你可以吗？让他弹他妈的想弹的。是的，你想弹什么就弹什么。我想让你弹你想弹的。这样吧。你来点歌。我来弹一小段。
No, no, you play it. You pick, you pick. See, gravity would be nice, too. Yeah, play all of it continued. Medley. Medley. I know, I'm at the age of doing a medley. I'll do a medley if you want. Yes. Hold on. Let me just load it up in my head.
不，不，你来弹。你挑，你挑。你看，重力（Gravity）也不错。是的，把整首连起来。串烧。串烧。我知道，我到了做串烧的年纪了。如果你想的话，我来做个串烧。好的。等一下。让我先在脑子里加载一下。
Okay. All right. It's not a silly little moment It's not strong before the ground This is the deep and dying breath of It's love that we've been working on and on Can't seem to hold you like I want to So I can fear you in my arms
好吧。好吧。这不是一个愚蠢的小时刻这不是落地前的坚强这是……这是我们一直在不断努力的爱似乎无法像我想的那样拥抱你所以我能在我的怀里感受到你
Nobody's gonna come to save you We put too many false alarms We go down You can see it too We go down And you know that with my dear We're slow dancing And a burning
没有人会来拯救你我们拉响了太多错误的警报我们坠落了你也能看到我们坠落了你知道亲爱的我们正在慢舞在熊熊燃烧的
Oh, too good Can I just keep going on this song? I was the one you always dreamed of You were the one I tried to draw How dare you say it's nothing to me Baby you're the only light I ever saw I made the most of all the sadness You'll be a bitch because you can
哦，太棒了能让我继续这首歌吗？我是你一直梦想的那个人你是我试图画出的人你怎么敢说这对我很冷漠宝贝，你是我见过的唯一的光我把所有的悲伤都发挥到了极致你会成为一个刻薄鬼，因为你可以
Or you try to hit me just to hurt me So you leave me feeling dirty Because you can understand We're going down We could see it too Ah We're going down And you know that when I dear
或者你试图打击我只是为了伤害我所以你让我觉得自己很肮脏因为你能理解我们正在坠落我们也能看到啊我们正在坠落你知道亲爱的当我们
We're slow dancing In a burning room And now, Sean, in other words I guess what I was trying to say with this song was Was all we Goodbye All we ever do is say
我们慢舞在熊熊燃烧的房间里现在，肖恩，换句话说我想我通过这首歌想表达的是我们所有的再见我们所做的一切都是
Goodbye She would say Goodbye She said to me Condescendingly Take a scene Take your life And plighted out in black and white
再见她会说再见她居高临下地对我说选个场景选择你的生活把它描绘成黑白的
Of the prime kings and the drama queens, I'd like to think the best of me. They love to tell you. Stay inside the song. You want to run through the hall of my high school. I want to scream at the top of my eyes. I can't see that. I just found out there's no such thing as the real world. Just a lie, you got to rise above.
在那些老牌国王和戏剧女王中，我想保持最好的自己。他们喜欢告诉你。留在歌里。你想跑过我高中的大厅。我想声嘶力竭地尖叫。我看不清。我刚发现根本没有什么真实的世界。只有一个谎言，你必须超越。
I just can't wait till my tin. your reunion, I'm gonna bust down the double doors. And when I stand on misdemean before you, you will know what all the time was for. Thank you. Now, Sean, I gotta say, great job, Sean. Great job, Sean. I mean, I think so.
我简直迫不及待地等到我的十岁。你的聚会，我要砸碎双扇门。当我站在你面前的轻罪面前时，你就会明白这一切时间都是为了什么。谢谢。现在，肖恩，我得说，干得好，肖恩。干得好，肖恩。我的意思是，我认为是的。
Belize. He's up there. Scotty might be in trouble, huh? I mean, that... What, that I did this photo? Well, no, I mean, I did. I mean, you guys had a real connection. I know.
伯利兹。他榜上有名。斯科蒂可能有麻烦了，哈？我的意思是，那……什么，我拍了这张照片？好吧，不，我的意思是，我确实拍了。我的意思是，你们之间真的很有默契。我知道。
I love that guy. Isn't that amazing? You guys? And I saw a bunch of you guys mouthing the lyrics too. You didn't know he was coming out here and you're big John Mayer fan. I love that.
我爱那家伙。这不是很神奇吗？你们俩？我看到你们很多人也在跟着哼唱歌词。你不知道他会来这里，而你是约翰·梅尔的超级粉丝。我喜欢这样。
I like what he said about vulnerability. I think more men should be more vulnerable in the world. I must agree. We talk about that a lot. And I think he's a brainiac and a sweetheart and a good person and I hope he finds love because he deserves it.
我喜欢他关于脆弱的言论。我认为世界上更多的男性应该更加脆弱。我必须同意。我们经常讨论这个。而且我认为他是个聪明人、大好人、一个好人，我希望他能找到真爱，因为他配得上。
That's right. There's a bucket out there with phone numbers for any single people out there. But I love that song, one of my favorite songs. I know. Great song. It sounded very good. Do you remember the name of it?
没错。外面有一个桶，里面装满了留给所有单身人士的电话号码。但我很喜欢那首歌，我最喜欢的歌之一。我知道。好歌。听起来非常好。你还记得它的名字吗？
All we ever do is say... Goodbye! Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbicob, and Michael Grant Terry. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们所做的一切就是说……再见！Smartless 是由 Rob Armjarf、Bennett Barbicob 和 Michael Grant Terry 100% 有机手工制作的。Smartless。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。